This is Jocko podcast number 50 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening
to be
or not to be
okay.
That is probably the most famous of all of Shakespeare's lines.
And in fact it's so famous that it's often unfortunately used as a punchline,
uses a joke
to be or not to be.
It becomes easy to forget.
Okay.
What Shakespeare is actually talking about.
He's talking about death
and more specifically in this case he's talking about suicide
and Prince Hamlet,
the character that delivers that famous line who's often called insane,
but who himself says,
I am essentially not in madness,
but mad in craft.
Meaning he is playing the role of insanity to further his own objectives.
But not everybody even agrees on that point.
But here's what hamlet does say
to be or not to be.
That is the question.
Yeah.
Whether tis nobler in the mind to suffer the slings and arrows of outrageous
fortune.
In other words he's talking about is it worth it to suffer through the problems
we have in life and he goes on or to take arms against a sea of troubles.
And by opposing
end them.
Meaning should we,
should we fight against the pain of life,
this sea of troubles.
And in that fight,
should we choose death,
which is the only alternative to life.
And he goes on
to die to sleep no more
and bias sleep to say we end the heartache and the thousand natural shocks that
flesh is heir to.
So he's saying that death lets you escape all these hardships of life in these
thousand natural shocks.
And he finishes it out.
Tizard consummation,
devout B,
two B wished for to die
to sleep.
He's saying that that is what we should wish for
to die.
And that is this most famous
soliloquy is about killing yourself.
It's about,
it's about suicide.
Now we have a guest on today,
and this is a guest who I've come to know since I sort of debuted in the world.
And in fact this guest happens to be the person that actually debuted me to the
world that brought me into the world.
His name is Tim Ferriss.
And in September of 2015 he interviewed me on his podcast just prior to the
release of my book,
extreme owners.
Now at the time,
I was certainly a a Tim Ferriss listener.
I'd read the four hour work week.
I listened to a bunch of his podcasts,
but I hadn't listened to all of them in.
And I think I had
kind of the broad view
that most people have of Tim,
the the Human Guinea pig,
the investor,
the author,
just,
you know,
Mister Smart,
successful,
healthy guy who's out there enjoying the fruits of life.
And,
and with all that stuff in my mind there I was in the first ever interview I had
ever actually done with anybody ever.
And it's a setup.
The setup is,
it's an interesting setup going into this for me,
right?
We're all alone.
I don't know,
Tim am not the most open person in the first place.
Tim,
we meet two hours before now we're in his house alone at a table and the
interview starts going kind of Jocko wish pretty quickly and I start going a
little bit heavy on some stuff.
Okay.
And at one point Tim asked me about books that I've read and it brought up about
face and,
and then I brought up Cormac McCarthy blood Meridian,
and I described how I liked that book because it captured
the darkness and not just the darkness of the world,
but the dark nature of human beings in the world.
And Tim,
after I describe that darkness,
you said something along the lines of like,
Hey Jocko,
I struggle with this.
How much should I voluntarily expose myself to darkness?
Because I've had my own ups and downs that I contend with [inaudible].
And then he kind of took that question from there and from that personal level,
and he really quickly transferred to into something that was more about the
world and about humanity in general.
But the initial question
that Tim started to ask,
it wasn't about the world
and it wasn't about humanity in general.
The question that Tim was asking was about Tim
and I didn't catch that during the interview.
All right?
It went right over my head.
But when I listened to the interview,
I caught it and I heard
and I heard that beneath this guy,
that we all see this happy go lucky exterior,
kind of a solid image of mental and physical and spiritual strength.
There was some darkness in there
and Tim and I were going back and forth a few weeks ago and he said something to
me,
you know,
I'm not sure if I'm aligned with the types of guests you normally have on your
podcast.
And thinking back instantly to that moment,
I said,
oh no,
Tim,
you,
you definitely are.
Because you
are a person,
you're a human.
And this is a podcast about human nature.
And despite all the success you've had,
you've had some challenges in your life.
You've had some dark times and you still do.
And we all do.
And people ask me
about suicide.
I mean,
most of the time at some indirect messaging or some messaging through Facebook,
but people will,
will ask me about suicide,
whether they're having those thoughts.
And I haven't really addressed it directly
because even though it's,
it's suicide has definitely impacted my life directly
in some
awful and horrible ways that I'll never forget,
but
I don't have that same
level of knowledge.
So
today we do have that level of knowledge and
we're going to dive into it.
So
without further ado,
Mr Tim Ferriss,
welcome to the show.
And thank you for coming on.
Thanks for having me on.
Now I don't even want to play around here.
I want to,
I want to get right in.
Don't want to get this hard stuff done.
I want to talk about this,
this book that you,
you just put out.
It's called tools of titans.
And in this book,
and I just got done telling you this,
you know,
I,
I looked and found the blog posts that you had originally written that's named a
very Tim Ferriss name.
In my opinion,
it's,
it's some practical thoughts on suicide,
right?
Only Tim would think about practical thoughts on suicide.
So,
and you sent me the book and I had found that blog past post and I'd read it,
but when you sent me the book,
I saw that you had put it in the book and I think that was awesome for you to do
that,
to put it in this book so that people have access to it.
So I want to get into this piece of it right now from the book and here we go.
Some practical thoughts on suicide.
In this chapter I'm going to talk about suicide and why I'm still on this
planet.
It might seem dark,
but the objective is to give hope and tools to those who need them.
It is a much larger number than you might imagine.
Okay.
I kept the following story secret from my family,
girlfriends and claw.
I closest friends for years recently,
however,
I hadn't experienced that shook me,
woke me up and I decided that it was time to share everything.
So despite the shame,
I might feel the fear that is making my palm sweat as I type this.
Allow me to get started.
Here we go.
So you had some,
you had some series hesitation on putting this out there in the first place.
I did it sat in drafts for between six and nine months with fits and starts
because I had a lot of doubt about my motivations for putting it out the good
that it might do,
the bad that it could indirectly that I couldn't foresee unforeseen consequences
and uh,
just the embarrassment and also the fear of how my family would respond.
There was a lot,
there are a lot of factors that kept it in my drafts folder for very long time.
And in this story that you tell here is,
is the story of what made you finally decide to,
to talk about it in the public forum and it,
what happened was a guy came up to you and said,
you would end up at an event,
a guy comes up to you and says,
Hey,
can you,
can you sign this for my brother?
It would mean a lot to him.
And you're,
you know,
you give them the hey,
no problem.
You're kind of notice that there's something odd about the way the guy's acting.
But you signed the book and a little while later as you leaving he comes up and
he says,
you know,
I got to talk to you and you say,
hey,
got to leave,
but what he got,
let's go walk with me and you find out that this guy's younger brother who you
had just signed the book for had recently killed himself at the age of 22
and this guy told you,
people listened to you,
Tim,
have you ever thought about talking about these things about suicide or
depression?
You might be able to save someone
and then you say,
here in the book,
I didn't know what to say.
I also didn't have an excuse.
Unbeknownst to him,
I had every reason to talk about suicide.
Some of my closest high school friends killed themselves.
Some of my closest college friends killed themselves
and I almost killed myself.
And you held that in for a long time.
Long thin.
There you are,
a public figure and you hadn't,
you had never talked about this.
Now,
as I said for me,
I certainly have brushed up against suicide starting with
my best friend when I was a kid,
a kid named Jeff and I had joined the navy and I was in seal training and I got
wait until we had kind of grown apart.
And uh,
I talked about this when I was on your podcast,
you know,
I grew up with in,
in our rural area in New England and there was a lot of hippies and just kids,
you know,
dead heads and whatnot.
And I didn't go in that direction.
But my really good friend did and he ended up getting heavily involved in drugs
and booze and everything else.
And he got involved with a girl and when they broke up,
be killed himself in a horrible way that I'm not even gonna talk about.
But I got word of it.
I was going through seal training and I get word that this kid,
you know,
that I was such good friends with,
killed himself.
And then on top of that,
now we go 1993
and again,
one of my best friends in the seal teams,
absolute stud of a individual of a human being,
but incredible athlete quarterback at the Naval Academy by the way,
record holder at the naval academy.
Just a hilarious guy,
leader of men,
just incredible human being
named Alton lead Grizzard.
He got murdered along with a female naval officer named Carrie O'neil.
They got murdered,
both of them by another navy officer who also went to the naval academy who then
killed himself.
So murder suicide.
And
I'll tell you what,
anybody that knew Griz,
I mean this was just devastating,
devastating.
Just damn near broke my heart.
And then most recently,
yeah,
in December of 2012
another seal that I knew
who was the commander of the seals in Afghanistan,
the commander of all the seals in Afghanistan on deployment in Afghanistan,
goes to a meeting,
gets done with a meeting,
goes to his room,
shoots himself in the head,
kills himself.
No,
no suicide note,
no strange behavior,
no indicators,
nothing.
And like I said,
this guy was in my sister pulled through and it's the whole team too.
I mean just a great guy,
respected,
see your
and boom
gone.
And I guess that's why I,
I,
I feel strongly about wanting to bring you on in and talk to you about this.
Cause I know you felt it personally.
You're talking about it and I,
but personally I actually have never wanted to go myself before.
Okay.
Now I will say there are times in my life where I,
where I cared less about living than other times.
And it certainly in combat I definitely accepted that I could die and I was okay
with it.
And there's probably times in combat where I crossed the line a little bit
towards the just straight bring it on,
let's do.
But I never seriously how had that,
you know,
that fault.
But it's something that I know is out there.
Like I said,
I've,
it's brushed up against me.
It's crushed me.
And when you say in this book that you almost killed yourself in,
and we'll talk about what got you there and how you ended up there.
But how real is that feeling when it hits you?
There's nothing really,
I think that the,
the delusion or the set of delusions that you find yourself in seem as real as
this table that we're sitting at as real,
as anything you see or hear and the voices in your head,
that internal dialogue,
that self talk is a powerful thing and it can be powerful in constructive ways
and it can be powerful and extremely destructive ways.
So for me it felt permanent.
It felt in escapable it felt concrete.
I felt like I had a column of evidence exhibit a throughZ to indicate that I
would be better off killing myself.
So it wasn't a desire to,
it wasn't a desire to end my own life.
It was a,
a desire to stop suffering and stop causing the suffering of others or what I
perceive to be inflicting on my loved ones and family members and so on and
feeling trapped.
I think above all it's feeling trapped and feeling alone.
Like you are flawed and in being flawed,
you are unique and you should just be just be sent back to the factory.
And that equals taking yourself out extremely real though.
It's definitely,
it was it,
it was as concrete is any emotion or any object or any interaction that you can
imagine and it's,
it's got to be weird now
and you say this like you're looking back at this now,
and of course this is so easy to see and go,
oh,
I was not thinking straight.
And right now you can tell it's not real.
Or those problems that you perceived,
you could tell that they weren't real problems,
they weren't unsolvable problems,
they weren't worth ending your life over.
But you get trapped in there.
And I think in particular you do get trapped.
And in my case there were say five or six different events that happened roughly
at the same time that caused me to spiral.
And as I spiraled,
I got to a point where I felt like I would never contribute anything meaningful
to other people or to the world because I was so handicapped by this
pessimistic,
dark view of the world and of myself.
And I was like,
well,
if that's the case,
why go through all this pain to try to solve these various problems when
clearly,
like you said,
in retrospect,
it's ludicrous.
I mean,
it's ridiculous,
but at the time it seemed anything,
but why not just control alt,
delete,
let's just shut this computer down.
You know,
I got,
I get to see this little bit right now.
Um,
you know,
I got kids and you know,
my,
I got teenage daughters and little things in the world that they think are the
most important,
great.
You know,
things in the whole world.
I mean,
literally like a dress or a pair of shoes you,
I'm like,
it's okay.
We can get you some more shoes or whatever.
It's,
you get to see a glimpse of what you're talking about just with any human,
any human,
anywhere that,
even in a workplace where someone's going through some problem at work and they
didn't get the report turned in on time and,
and they're acting like it's the end of the world and it's actually the end of
nothing.
And actually in many cases means almost nothing.
Hmm.
Almost nothing.
I'm gonna go back to the book.
So you say to Silas,
which is the guy that had come up and asked you to sign a book.
You come up and say,
oh you,
you say,
look,
I'm sorry for your loss.
And then you had sort of the internal talk once again with yourself and you say,
I'd failed his brother by you being such a coward in my writing.
How many others had I failed these questions swam in my mind.
And then you look at Silas and you say,
I will write about this.
I promise
that's probably when you made your first decision to get this draft go.
And actually you said the end with that,
I got in to the elevator and I added my own phrase on here and you should have
had be edit this,
but you said,
and with that I got in the elevator and I added and headed down
because the next part of this is called into the darkness.
And you've got a great quote in here that I'd never heard before.
The quote is they tried to bury us.
Okay.
They didn't know we were seeds.
And
I think that's an awesome quote.
They tried to bury us.
They didn't know we were seeds.
And I can tell you
that I didn't bury these thoughts and these feelings and I'm,
I'm thinking back,
I'm just trying to kind of deconstruct where,
where my attitude came from and all this stuff.
And I think that when I grew up,
I listened to some things that may,
that debt,
just pull those seeds right out of the ground.
They were plain as day when you grow up listening to kind of music that I
listened to,
just dark heavy music that sang about this stuff.
And I'll tell you there's a,
uh,
one of the best pieces of music that you can hear on this subject and I don't
even know it's dark,
but Henry Rollins on an album called lifetime,
there's a,
a song called gun in mouth blues.
And I saw him perform at many times live
and
it like took me through those emotions and you'd go on Youtube and try and it
doesn't deliver the way it was when I was a kid when I was 14 or 15 years old
and I got a guy on stage,
a grown man to me at that time who was,
you know,
25 or something,
whatever Rollins was at that time.
And he's singing about that.
And so for me,
I'm thinking to myself,
well those seeds weren't buried for me.
They were out.
Right.
I was thinking about that,
but I wasn't like I was okay with me,
you know what I'm saying?
And I
in a lot of the music that I listened to back then talked about that stuff.
So I didn't bury those seeds ever.
Really.
And
is that something that you did,
obviously you put the quote in here,
but how do you see yourself,
how did you bury those seats?
So the,
I included the quote for a few reasons.
The first is effectively exactly what you alluded to.
So these internal demons,
these self doubts,
the self criticisms I felt were a huge weakness.
And so to compete to whether that's in sports,
academics or otherwise,
I kept that all in.
So I actually grew up on the same music or similar music,
but I was listening to slayer.
I was listening to a lot of dark music,
which I can still appreciate the double bass and so on and slayer album.
But for me,
because I never,
I never chose to express any of that.
I had no release valve.
So it actually fed,
I think in a way this type of self loathing and uh,
it could have been biochemical in the first place.
I don't know quite frankly.
And I mean my family at least on one side has a history of a extended depression
and schizophrenia and so on.
Uh,
schizophrenia less so,
but so maybe it started there.
Who knows?
I don't know what the origin is.
Um,
and sign include that quote is a reminder of two things.
A,
when you try to suffocate or Barry or district guard these thoughts and emotions
as opposed to contend with them or deal with them in some fashion,
they are seeds and you're pouring fertilizer on them when you try to neglect and
avoid them.
The second reason I put that in is be to remind myself,
if you feel like external concert,
uh,
if you,
if you feel like external circumstances or external actors,
meaning people
are stacking the deck deck against you or trying to bury you,
right?
Trying to defeat you in some fashion,
you are
the seed so you can recover from that,
uh,
and their strength to be found in the struggle.
So I included it for both of those reasons.
Yeah,
that's,
and I've talked about that before,
this idea of battling demons,
right?
And one of the things I,
I said on the podcast,
I want an earlier podcast,
as I just said,
don't let the demons ambush you.
Don't let them sneak around in there.
You got to bring them out.
You got to,
you got to bring them out and confront them and deal with them.
Don't try and bury them,
bring them out.
And so that's,
that's very similar.
And also when you were a kid,
this is,
this is also interesting because you were an overachiever as kid,
right?
I was good in school.
I was very,
very small.
I got the shit kicked out of me routinely up until about sixth grade.
But you wrestled,
you,
you are a good wrestler,
right?
I did,
yeah.
I got up to a national level towards the end of high school.
I did not wrestle in college since it was title nine at Princeton where I ended
up going.
But I was a,
uh,
academically,
certainly a high achiever and a good rest and a really good wrestler.
Academic,
we don't,
I mean you're going to Princeton,
right?
So that's pretty much,
and then you land at Preston and kicking ass.
No,
no.
I,
I had very supportive parents did really well in school,
got to Princeton and realized everyone was at that level or higher.
And it's a different playing fields and the,
and is that one of the things you think that as you started thinking about this
darkness,
you're looking at these other people going,
oh,
they don't have that,
I got to bury it because they're all,
they're all smart as me and great athletes and so I,
I'm competing with them and I don't want to have that chalk against me of saying
all,
you know,
I'm a little bit sad today.
That's bad.
I'm going to be positive.
Uh,
for sure.
I think that was part of it.
The,
on one hand,
I enjoy competing.
So having a bunch of stronger competitors didn't bother me at all.
I was actually pretty thrilled about it,
but I did feel like to compete on this higher level playing field,
uh,
it would not behoove me or helping me to walk around bemoaning my weaknesses at
all.
So I didn't,
and I felt like particularly being the,
going to that school is a real stretch for my entire family and extended family.
And I felt like I had to deliver and
there was no pressure from my parents whatsoever.
But I don't need anyone else's pressure.
I can deliver plenty of that for myself.
And I felt that a lot was riding on that and I had the plan,
of course,
as many people might have in their lives is get good grades in high school and
go to a good college,
get great grades in college,
go to get to a fantastic job and so on and so forth.
So which led up to,
I mean a lot of the catalyzing events later in college in senior year,
that that were really the,
the straws that broke the camel's back because I was,
I was,
I wasn't always near the precipice.
I mean I was healthy for long stretches of time.
Then I'd have maybe a depressive period,
but it was manageable.
Oftentimes coincided with winter.
I don't handle that type of weather very well,
which is part of the reason that I now live on the west coast.
And did you,
did you,
were you self aware of that are very,
where a very weird at the time,
probably less aware of the weather having the impact that it did,
but,
but you would literally say,
Oh man,
I'm feeling down right now.
This is one of my secular things.
It'll be okay.
Definitely and used.
That's pretty introspective for a kid.
Well,
I spent a lot of time in my own head and there are benefits that come from that.
You can get very good at academics and then sometimes you're just your own worst
enemy.
So being trapped in my head,
uh,
is not always the,
the,
the carnival that you might think it to be.
Sometimes it is for sure.
Uh,
depending on what I've eaten or imbibed a as well.
But that's a separate podcast,
the,
uh,
but I've learned to manage it and we're jumping a little bit ahead,
but for instance,
uh,
and we'll get to it I'm sure,
but the,
the writing of the senior thesis,
yeah,
that was a major trigger for a lot of reasons.
Now,
for instance,
you know,
writing the book that's sitting in front of us,
I flew a researcher from Canada to be with me almost 24,
seven while I was in the final six to eight weeks of writing this book.
Why did I need him to come from Canada to be there in person?
No,
absolutely not.
But I wanted another human around so I wouldn't go red room,
red room.
And what would you write?
700 pounds.
You're going to end up,
we ended up in the red dog other than the normal room.
Uh,
so you're right that we do start getting into this.
Um,
let's talk about this,
but can I,
can I,
can I say absolutely.
One of the reasons,
and you did give me a 20 to say this,
so in fairness,
but one of the reasons I recommend your podcast so much is because you talk
about the darkness and you talk about how common it is.
And I think the reason,
for instance,
out of the blue,
one of my friends,
super handsome guy,
wealthy family ladies throwing themselves at him in high school kills himself.
Out of the blue,
no one expected it.
And I think that when you find people in any circumstance who end up taking it
to the that point,
it's because they think it is a rare flaw there.
The one in a thousand who happens to be so fucked up beyond repair that it's not
worth continuing.
And by exposing and discussing the darkness,
you realize,
I mean that's 50% of the people or more 50% of the time.
It is extremely common no matter what you think your defect is,
anger,
depression,
you have plenty of people to keep you company.
So,
uh,
in
any case crowded up there,
it's cure how it is.
So that's,
that's,
that's a great point.
Um,
at,
let's go into this then when,
when we go into what happened and some of the things that that went down,
this downward spiral is what you call it.
And,
and,
and again,
in here,
I'm going back to the book in hindsight,
it's incredible how trivial some of it seems.
And in,
I put my note in there the next night,
it's like,
cause you're detached from it now.
And that's such a key thing I talk about all the time.
Right?
We want to remain detached from things.
We don't want to get wrapped up in the emotions.
It would be we want to stay back because when you detach from it,
every answer is so clear.
When you're not wrapped up in it.
This is this stuff that,
that that happened to you.
Sure it was it challenging?
Yes.
Did it suck it?
Was it hard?
Yes,
of course,
but detached from it.
Now you're looking at it.
You're you.
You might literally be laughing at this stuff now.
Oh,
I do.
I mean,
I wrote it and that's why at the end there's this part
towards the end.
It's like many of you might be thinking,
wait a second,
a Princeton student got a really bad grade.
Who fucking who?
Like,
are you kidding me?
Yeah,
but that's the whole point,
right?
That's the whole point is that you don't,
is that people we don't detach.
We get absorbed in this stuff and it becomes our world.
So you get what I'm going back to the book.
I include wording like impossible situation,
which was reflective of my thinking at the time and it begins senior year slated
to graduate in June of 1999 somewhere in the next six months.
All these things happen.
First you fail to make it to the final interviews for Mckinsey Consulting and if
some other company and you start losing confidence,
so this is the first time you get kind of a little bit beat and your life a
little bit for sure.
I was doing it
extremely well academically and all of a sudden I didn't know what I was doing
wrong and just just to provide a little bit of context and it's in Doug,
this is like,
I have this huge smirk on my face because it's so ridiculous,
you know,
in hindsight,
but at Princeton or any ivy league school,
really,
there are only a handful of industries that recruit.
Primarily you find management consulting firms and investment banks.
Why?
Because they want to hire you and then use your pedigree Princeton so that they
can charge their clients.
In the case of management consulting,
$500 an hour for photocopying,
right?
It's not it at all,
as exotic as it might seem,
but everyone is competing for those slots and I didn't know what to do next.
So I just decided being very driven in that way,
I'm going to compete for what everyone is going after because I think I can beat
them now.
This is the first time that I really felt like,
Hey,
I got my ass handed to me with n B.
This is important.
If I lose a wrestling match,
I know why I lost here.
I didn't know what was wrong.
So that unknown variable hit me reasonably hard.
I can imagine that now you're doubting everything in a wrestling match.
You go,
hey,
my conditioning wasn't good.
Or Hey,
my takedowns one on point in here,
you're just going to what was wrong?
I don't know what was wrong.
Exactly.
Something's wrong with me.
And no one could tell me.
Even the people that interviewed me,
they wouldn't give me the feedback.
So that's,
that's point a,
uh,
very shortly thereafter have a longterm girlfriend break up with me,
which again,
in isolation I think I could have weathered and I head weathered many times
before,
but I'm kind of relying on my heels a little bit.
And then my,
hold on,
I'm going to go to the book here because you give some pretty good specifics on
that.
She breaks up with you because this is from the book because I became insecure
during that period,
wanted more time with her and was massively disruptive to her varsity sports.
But my point is that these things compounded,
right?
You get insecure and you think,
why didn't they,
why did they,
why didn't they hire me?
And then you look at your girl and to say,
well,
I'll go to her for comfort.
Hey,
but you know,
I need more from you.
And she's going,
which all humans do,
which is,
oh,
you're,
you want to throw yourself at me?
I don't need you.
Exactly.
It was not only that,
but so she wakes up like you do and I tend to go to bed when you do.
And so I would want to have these late night conversations and it,
it screwed up or a competition.
And I mean,
and uh,
it was,
it was extremely important to her,
rightly so.
She was a varsity athlete,
sell exit stage,
left girlfriend,
gone.
And then the,
the primary piece of this sort of the,
in my mind,
the checkmate for a loss was the interactions that I had with my
counselor or thesis advisor.
And I was in the East Asian studies department.
I started in psychology,
then I moved from neuroscience to East Asian Studies to focus on language
acquisition.
And uh,
this,
this senior thesis,
just to put this in perspective,
not every college or university has a mandatory senior thesis.
Princeton does,
and it breaks a lot of kids.
So I'm not unique in this,
but I thought I was at the time.
It breaks.
A lot of kids,
you say breaks,
like they don't graduate because they don't finish it or they just get
emotionally,
they go through total turmoil and it did test above.
And what I realized after the fact is a lot of kids kill themselves actually,
uh,
at uh,
many of these top schools and I'm sure other schools,
but it's,
it's such a pressure cooker or the kids perceive it that way.
God,
I feel old column kids.
But regardless,
it's such a pressure cookers for you Tim.
It's very,
very common.
So it,
it really does break a lot of kids but it's generally,
let's just call it,
and it varies by department,
but 60 to a hundred pages,
sometimes longer and it can count for 25% of your four year or there's just say
cumulative departmental GPA.
It is weighed very,
very,
very heavily.
So even if you've had straight A's,
it can really throw a wrench into the works if you want to finish with a very
strong GPA.
Now keep in mind,
I had already been turned down for jobs and this is so they go together here,
lose my smile,
crutch that's keeping me up,
which is the girlfriend.
And then at that point I,
I am researching for my thesis.
Everything's going fine so far.
And I meet with the head of curriculum design for Berlitz International,
which is New York.
Princeton had a great dinner and he said,
it's really too bad you're graduating and x number of months because we actually
have a fantastic job for you that I could give you right now.
You'd be a perfect fit.
So I think to myself,
well this is going to solve for different problems.
I don't know what I want to do.
I'm not getting picked up by these other companies.
Why don't I take some time off and figure out the job and then figure out the
thesis.
Now the thesis,
I'm going a little bit out of order here,
but the thesis was important because I had a meeting with my thesis advisor who
had his own research agendas and and as is very common in academics,
professors will utilize the help of students at times to integrate things or
research things for them and slave labor,
slave labor,
and the,
he dropped to a pile of say 50 60 pages of original Japanese research.
So this is all in Japanese to integrate into my thesis.
It wasn't fit.
It was,
it was a round peg in a square hole.
It would be nearly impossible to put into my thesis,
but I decided,
all right,
well he's the advisor,
he's tenured.
This is mandatory.
It's not an optional.
Then I figured out,
oh my God,
well I could take this job,
take a year off,
do a great job on thesis,
come back,
problem solve them.
So I have a meeting with my thesis advisor to tell him that I'm going to do
this,
not realizing at the time also that his,
his research needs of me are time sensitive and he lost it.
He basically,
he basically said,
oh,
you're just going to cop out and take all this time off school.
Well,
better be the best thesis I've ever seen in my life and not so subtly saying,
I'm going to tell you if this is what you're going to do.
I'm going to,
I'm going to tank you.
And I don't think I was misreading that and I was completely bewildered then
really upset,
meaning sad,
depressed,
then really angry and I was like,
you know what?
This is bullshit.
This is Princeton University focused on the Undergrad,
this is,
this should be a solvable problem.
So I go to people in the administration and I tell them what happened.
And collectively the response was effectively he wouldn't do that because once
you have your immunity bracelet in the form of tenure,
you're not getting voted off the island.
And,
uh,
even people within the department would not pick a fight with him,
or even really seek to clarify it.
And,
uh,
that was when I felt totally hopeless.
And uh,
that was kind of the beginning of the end as I saw
it.
At that point.
It's very important to note.
I was not suicidal.
I just felt completely trapped and without options.
I ended up regardless taking the year off.
Uh,
and that is where things got particularly dark because I went from being
surrounded by students,
didn't have the girlfriend that I was in a social environment to working for
Berlitz.
But what I didn't realize it was going to be the,
the setup,
the logistics was working remotely.
What does that mean?
That means that I'm off campus now with two of my friends who go to work every
day,
normal hours,
and I'm left in a bedroom or a living room alone to try to work on my thesis and
to do work for Berlitz completely solo.
That is where the carnival in my head is a very dangerous thing.
I'm outmatched right.
And um,
we can,
we can keep going.
So the other thing that struck me as once that happens now,
you also start to see your friends graduated,
graduate and you're all done.
They're done.
They're gone.
Got the heavy burden still on you.
Yeah.
That was that.
That was,
seemed to be a huge piece of it as as well.
And then I'm going to go to the book.
Back to the book here.
Your,
your coping mechanism is to cover myself in sheets,
minimize time awake and hope for a miracle.
Okay.
No miracle arrives.
One afternoon as I'm wandering through a Barnes and noble with no goal in
particular,
I chanced upon a book about suicide.
It's right there in front of me on a display table.
Perhaps.
This is the miracle.
I sit down and read the entire book,
taking copious notes into a journal,
including other books listed in the bibliography
for the first time in ages.
I'm excited about research.
Okay.
In a sea of uncertainty and hopeless situations.
I feel like I've found hope.
The final solution,
the idea just appears in a book.
Yeah.
And you go full Tim Ferriss on this thing.
With the same enthusiasm and rigor and OCD that I tackle anything.
I,
I dove into that and uh,
went to Firestone library,
great library at Princeton to check out as many of those reference books
possible to do my research.
And one of them was not in a,
one of the key pieces and swipe.
I made a request put in a request to get notified and I was living,
I think it was in,
which is near Princeton
at the time.
Yeah.
And I think it's worth noting that I was past the point of deciding,
yeah.
I was in planning.
You say that in the book and I'll just read it.
It's important to mention that by this point I was past deciding the decision
was obvious to me.
I had somehow failed,
painted myself into this ridiculous corner,
wasted a fortune on school that didn't care about me.
So what would be the point of doing otherwise to repeat these types of mistakes
forever to be a hopeless burden to myself and my family and my friends.
Fuck that the world was better off without a loser who couldn't figure out this
basic shit.
Okay,
what would I ever contribute?
Nothing.
So the decision was made and I was in full on planning mode.
In this case,
I'm a dangerously good at planning.
I have four to six scenarios all spaced out,
start to finish
or sorry,
specked out,
start to finish,
including potential collaborators and covers when needed.
So as you just said,
as you just pointed out,
you were full on Tim Ferriss' researched,
complete decision made going forward.
Figure out the best way to execute this
and make it happen.
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
I remember it actually.
Something that's not in there.
I recall,
I recall when I had the plans and then it was a matter of scheduling and I was
waiting for that last book to see if I missed any research before proceeding.
But I had driven to Firestone taken out these books and I was very lethargic.
I remember,
I mean this coincides with this type of deep depression,
just very tired all the time.
And uh,
laid down in my van,
I might eat my used minivan,
hand me down from my mom after going to Firestone and just slept for like three
or four hours and woke up and I was like,
okay,
let's just get this done.
Let's figure it out and put it on the calendar.
And the,
what prevented that he was,
yeah,
pure luck.
I had forgotten that instead of using my Lawrenceville address,
I hadn't changed my address with the registrar.
So my mail was going back to my home address where my parents lived on long
island.
And so my mom gets this postcard in the mail.
I mean,
thank God this didn't happen a few years ago,
would've been via email.
She wouldn't have seen it.
And it said in effect a good news,
the book on suicide that you reserved is now available at Firestone library for
pickup.
So I got a very nervous call from my mom,
which I did not expect dangerous plans.
Did you,
did you think your mom does,
your mom sends it?
Oh yeah,
I could tell.
I mean her,
her voice was,
was very shaky and uh,
I quickly tap danced and talk my way out of it and I said,
oh no,
no,
no.
It's a friend at Rutgers.
He could,
he couldn't get it at his library.
So I may,
I reserved it at Firestone,
but it shocked me out of my self imposed false reality.
And it was,
it sounds so odd to say,
but it was the first time that I realized my suicide would effect,
no matter how cleverly I laid it out,
it would ruin the lives of people around me because I thought,
well,
let me figure out a scenario where I can make it look like a complete accident.
It won't look like suicide.
It'll just look like an accidental death.
And then I really,
I really figured it out and
it didn't matter.
It didn't matter.
I realized after that phone call that did your mom confront you with it?
She asked me about it and I was very fast to come up with the Rutgers lie.
Did she say like,
Hey Tim,
are you okay?
She did.
She did,
and we love,
you know,
we,
we love you.
Right?
And it wasn't a 32nd conversation and it was a longer conversation and there
were followup phone calls.
Props to mom for picking up on that.
Yeah.
So that was a
dodging.
A bullet,
metaphorically.
Now I a millimeter,
I'm going to go into this here.
It's sort of you,
you get through that.
You kind of get through what you just said.
You realize that this wasn't just about you,
this was going to hurt everybody.
You get through that and then you say,
the very next week I decided to take the rest of my year off,
truly off to hell with the thesis and focus on physical and mental health.
That's how the entire sumo story of the 1999 Chinese kickboxing Sansar
championships came to be.
If you read the four hour work week,
so you go on a full on year off,
just complete.
Now my question for you on that
is it,
what about normal people,
right?
Normal people that can't take a full on year off,
they got to find another way to get their focus off the what's going on in their
brain at their work and get out of that carnival and focus on their mental and
physical health while they're working their job,
taking care of their kids,
doing whatever that is they have to do for sure.
How's a normal person pulled that off?
Well,
there are,
I think a few strategies and tactics that I have used and continue to use.
So it's critical that people understand.
It's not like I summited the mountain,
slayed the Dragon,
and I'm done.
This is,
this is,
uh,
this is a movie that tends to like groundhog day repeat itself.
Not necessarily that intensely,
but if you are predisposed to periods of darkness,
as many people are,
you need to develop coping strategies and it's not so much the year off.
It was a focus on other things that helped.
And there are a few,
I mean looking back on it now I have a better tool kit.
The first is people talk about mind over matter,
mind over body,
mine,
everybody,
this type of stuff.
I think body over mind is extremely underrated.
So if you can't get out of your head,
get into your body number one,
that is the number one get out and move.
And really things didn't change for me dramatically until I started oddly
enough,
getting punched in the head,
going to the,
the toughest boxing gym I've ever seen in Trenton,
New Jersey where I was the only guy not on work release.
So I don't recommend that therapy for everyone,
but uh,
you know,
one broken nose,
a lot of bloody sparring sessions later I was feeling more like my old self.
So if you can't get out of your mind,
get into your body I think is very important.
There are a lot of good biochemical reasons for this.
I'll back that up too.
And,
and uh,
Tim Kennedy who is a MMA fighter,
just an awesome guy.
He posted something on Instagram of a,
a month ago or something like that and Facebook and whatever.
And basically he was saying he's addressing PTSD and,
and that sort of darkness,
right?
And he basically said,
look guys,
get out.
Go work out,
go push yourself.
And it's very similar to what I tell people like,
hey man,
do you know,
do Jujitsu,
lift weights,
sprint surf,
go get outside,
get into your body.
So I think that's universally,
I universally agree with that statement.
Let me
lay out a couple of super concrete recommendations and I should say in advance,
I'm not a doctor,
I don't play one on the Internet.
So you may need a,
certainly there are many people who need a medical interventions,
uh,
whether it's pharmaceutical or,
or otherwise.
In my case,
a few things that very much help with or without other adjuncts,
cold therapy.
So cold exposure and this has been studied very,
very effective as a supplemental or a singular therapy for antidepressive
purposes.
It's very,
very effective.
So I routinely,
and when I'm home in San Francisco for instance,
even in La,
on long island in the winter I take short cold showers,
pure cold showers,
and a van Gogh for instance,
when he lopped off as a year and was put into treatment,
he had two ice baths every day.
That was one of the treatment protocols and it's,
it's been looked at quite closely in the last few years was a cold exposure one.
So even if you don't get outside of the house,
that's an option.
You're going to take showers hopefully.
Anyway.
Uh,
then you have,
I,
if you can afford it,
I think a good test to have performed is conference of bloodwork,
look at micronutrient deficiencies in particular.
So you,
you could have,
this is very common with depleted,
uh,
ground soil,
selenium deficiency,
zinc deficiency,
copper deficiencies,
these affect hormone production and much more and can be fixed relatively easily
once you identify them.
I have friends,
for instance,
one was deficient in selenium,
was going through depressive period and he started eating Brazil nuts,
very high in selenium content.
And he called me,
he called me a week later.
He said,
I feel like I'm on cocaine now.
That's a dramatic example.
Uh,
and no,
you shouldn't use cocaine,
uh,
to fix your depression.
But bloodwork I think is if you get your car checked more often than you get
your body checked,
you need to rearrange your priorities.
Stoicism would be the next one.
Uh,
I find Seneca in particular,
uh,
moral letters to Luke Ileus.
Marcus Aurelius,
people tend,
if they read both,
either be full on Marcus,
a released guys or fall on Seneca guys.
And uh,
there's not a whole lot of overlap.
I tend to read Seneca,
but I will listen to say one of the letters,
letters of Luke Ileus every few days.
And if I'm going through a tough period,
I will listen to a 15 minute letter every day in the morning as I walked to say,
get a cup of coffee.
And what stoicism helps to teach you at its core,
I think,
or what it represents is an operating system for being nonreactive in high
stress situations.
And high stress is relative high stress could be going to the DMV and waiting in
line for some people.
But stoicism is also not just something you read,
it's a practice.
So there's a fear setting and fear rehearsal is very important.
So the practicing the worst case is something that I'll do regularly.
For instance,
taking a few days of every month to fast.
I do that,
uh,
taking a few days,
every month or every quarter to sleep on your kitchen floor in a sleeping bag
and eat oatmeal for a few days in a realize even if I have to quit my job,
even if I get fired from my job because a lot of concerns for many people or
financial,
I'll be fine.
Things are fine,
things are manageable.
So I spend a lot of time defining the worst case scenarios,
not just being vaguely afraid of bad things happening and practicing them so
that I build up some level of immunity and not immunity.
But it's an inoculation.
It's like getting a flu shot.
Yeah.
Stress and occupations and what we did in the seal teams to each other.
You go through our training for all kinds of combat stress and that way when get
in these scenarios in real life,
you're kind of used to it.
Exactly.
And did one of my other favorite quotes,
and I'm probably not going to get the pronunciation right on this name,
but a locus,
I think it is,
it says we do not rise to the level of our hopes.
We fall to the level of our training.
And that applies to a lot more of than military applies to everything.
Uh,
so,
so those are a few recommendations.
I do think I'd be remiss if I didn't mention some type of meditation or
mindfulness practice,
which can take dozens of forms.
It can take the form of exercise,
anything with a repetitive motion or anything.
Quite frankly,
that forces you to be present,
state aware.
If you're performing Olympic lifting,
I guarantee you're not thinking about your to do list
or the argument that you had with a coworker.
That's,
you know,
I think it was when I was doing a follow up for the first podcast that I did
with you and somebody asked me about meditation and I was like,
no,
I don't meditate.
I guess what I do do surf,
Jujitsu,
weightlift,
all this other stuff.
So that kind of falls into,
again,
I don't know,
cause I,
you know,
when you say do you meditate?
My answer's no,
I don't meditate.
You don't see me sitting in a corner with my legs crossed Indian style chanting.
Right.
I don't do that.
Do I get those benefits that people talk about?
Do I feel them when I'm on the Jujitsu Mat or when I'm Olympic weightlifting or
when I'm doing whatever these physical activities that I do?
I guess I do.
I guess that's where it is.
And I think my word that I go back to all the time is being able to detach
already said it once a day is,
is being able to detach from these situations,
detach from these,
these stresses that are there.
And,
and actually going back to the book here,
you say,
I returned to Princeton,
turned in my now finished thesis to my still Sour Advisor,
get chewed up in my thesis defense and I don't give a fuck.
And I think that is a very powerful tool.
That is a very powerful tool.
And it got me through all kinds of things.
And I'll tell you specifically like,
oh,
things are going bad at work would fire me go,
go ahead you,
you,
you won't find me.
Do it.
Bring it on.
I'll,
I'll find another job.
I'll go do something else.
You know,
even in the seal teams,
you know,
in the,
in my book I talked about this horrible situation that happened with the
fratricide and that was the beginning of deployment.
Well,
as things continued on deployment more,
no,
it's not like the bad thing stopped there.
Other bad things are gonna happen.
And what I knew was that I was doing the best job I possibly could do.
And if you guys above me in the chain of command want to call them,
fire me,
bring it.
And it wasn't that I actually didn't care,
but I kind of told myself I didn't care.
And when you,
when you release yourself of that stress of caring,
you can actually perform beggar.
You perform better when you say you don't want it.
And we talk about with fighters all the time,
fighters will be in an event and maybe they have a hard match and they barely
get through and then they go,
you know what?
Screw this,
I'm done.
I don't even care if I went to Lewis.
They go out there and have the performance of a lifetime because they relieve
themselves with that stress.
So sometimes not caring is one of the best antidotes for do,
performing better.
But it's very contradictory because you're saying,
okay,
I've got to perform really well,
so what am I doing?
I'm not going to care but I want to perform well.
But you've got to,
and I used to say this with guys would deal with girls,
right?
In the seal teams.
You got the guys they're going through,
you know they're,
they're young guys,
right?
They're 20 years old,
22 years old.
And so they get these relationship prompts and sometimes you've got to help them
through that.
And one of the things I'd say,
I'd say,
listen,
I didn't listen,
but they would be sad because they whatever.
And I'd say,
listen man,
you've got to not care.
And then I'd say,
Oh,
you can't just act like you don't care.
You have to actually
not care.
That's what you actually have to act to actually not care.
And if you do that,
you're good and you can walk away.
And somebody asked me that the other day on Twitter,
how do you get over,
uh,
how do you get over someone that you love that doesn't want you anymore?
And I was like,
wish them luck.
Walk away,
don't look back,
don't look back.
You've got to not care.
And I think when you set,
when you wrote that in the book right there,
I think that's a powerful thing.
It is.
And a want to look at the ingredients that led to that,
or at least one of them.
Uh,
a key component in that entire story is after deciding,
after having the mom intervention,
after deciding to focus on other things,
getting the thesis done,
but not staring at pages on the floor in my house by myself,
12 hours a day
I,
I was offered an opportunity,
it was half joking,
but from a friend of mine I had wrestled with who is going to be competing in
the sand show nationals,
Chinese kickboxing.
So that became a focus.
That became a clear goal where I knew input in output out in a garbage in,
garbage out,
good training in probably good results out.
Maybe I get knocked out.
But there's always that chance.
And the reason this is important,
you don't need to have a large athletic event.
What I've realized I accidentally did then and now I always do is much like,
and I think you think don't care.
Another way that maybe you could phrase it as not being preoccupied by it.
Right?
And if you're an investor,
let's just say you're not a full time investor.
How do you create that peace of mind?
You diversify your portfolio so you don't have all your eggs in one basket.
You can do that in life in a number of ways.
One of them is diversifying your identity.
So the way that I had set myself up for failure is all of my worth was set up
and whether this thesis would be a success or not,
and there were factors outside of my control that could affect that.
What I tried to do now,
and I recommend this to startup founders all the time,
I'm like,
look,
if your startup is the way you measure your entire worth as a human being,
there are factors outside of your control that could tank,
macro,
economic or otherwise competitive,
et cetera.
You can't have it dictated by how well your company is doing that day.
So for instance,
why don't I show you how to do it?
Very simple deadlifting protocol.
And therefore,
as a result,
even if your company is having the most difficult quarter imaginable,
if you're putting 10 pounds on your deadlift towns on a Max man,
all good.
That's a winning week.
And so I try to have at least three primary goals,
which would seem to d d to distract me.
Maybe for someone who isn't predisposed to depression and darkness,
you can have one singular goal.
For me,
having say three provides me with that divert that identity diversification.
Yeah.
And also the,
it sounds like the,
you're not going to pick goals that are counterproductive.
I mean,
you can run a good company and still increase your dead lift hundred percent
work on your breath hold and then things are going to,
they're all complimentary.
They're all going to help.
Exactly.
They're all complimentary.
And I should also say,
this is going back to the meditation piece and meditation is terrible word.
I mean,
it needs a complete brand overhaul.
It's just ludicrous.
Carries a lot of baggage with it.
Uh,
another option for getting your monkey mind out of your head so that you can
function properly is to,
and we had a funny exchange on Twitter about this,
but is to journal in the morning and really you can look at morning pages.
I won't get into it now,
but the stream of consciousness writing for three pages,
we'll very often show you how stupidly trivial your concerns are.
Uh,
it makes it concrete when you try to write it out and you're like,
wait,
that doesn't make any sense.
Why am I going to take that one step further?
You want to know what it actually does.
Well in my mind,
what it actually does when I'm writing something,
cause I now write for my own podcast,
right?
When you write,
your forced to detach from what you're writing,
100% forced to detach from it.
So when I'm writing something and you're looking at it,
it's you're not,
it's not in you anymore.
It's out there.
So that is a good way to detach.
It's by writing something down.
That's another thing that happens when you do pros and cons list,
right?
Oh,
I'm going to,
hey,
I don't know what decision I'm gonna make.
I'm gonna do pros and cons.
Well,
all you're doing is physically detaching,
physically pulling those things,
those ideas out of your brain,
putting them on a paper and now you're detached from them.
And you can make a good decision.
I hate when I agree with you,
Mr Tim Ferris
makes they mixed the Internet so much less fun or it
Gary,
but a few other,
uh,
recommendations one would be,
and this is something that I've used as a coping mechanism often if you can't
make yourself happy and happiness is a word is really problematic I think.
And chasing it tends to mean you're not going to catch it by the way.
But if you,
if you are in a low state or a depressive state and you can't figure out how to
make yourself happy,
just try to make other people happy.
And it seems cliched,
Kumbaya,
but it's like,
look,
something as simple and this is something that I do as paying for the coffee,
for the coffee,
for the person behind you in line at Starbucks can actually have a significant
impact on the wellbeing they do you experience in today.
Something like that.
Or like,
sometimes I'll just walk in a bit.
All right,
it's a Friday.
There's six people in this coffee shop.
All right.
Round a coffee on me.
Like,
it's,
it's such a simple thing to do,
but cheapest therapy you will,
you will ever have.
I don't know what I do.
What's that?
Kind of similar to that,
but it's a little bit different
when I interact with some,
let's say I'm not a coffee drinker bullets,
I'm in a restaurant,
but you know,
a seven 11,
right?
A seven 11,
I'm going in there.
I got to pick up whatever bottle of water when I interact with the person that's
selling me a bottle of water at seven 11 who's making $8 and 25 cents an hour,
I treat that person like a human being.
Yeah.
I said,
hey,
how's it going?
Yeah,
just this bottle water Thursday hot out there,
isn't it?
Hey,
hope you have a good day.
I just do that because I always see people in the world that treat those other
people like they're not people.
And I think that just dehumanizes you as an individual.
So somebody that's cleaning toilets and is coming out of the thing with uh,
with uh,
the bag of garbage and whatever and the,
hey man,
how's it going?
Everything cool,
you know,
day thanks,
stop.
Something like that though.
I think those are uh,
important and I definitely did the,
the way you put it in the book is if you can't seem to make yourself happy,
do little things to make other people happy.
Very effective magic trick.
Focus on others instead of yourself.
Totally agree with that one.
Going to the gym to your other ones you put in here is going to the gym move for
at least 30 minutes.
I tell this,
this is like the solution to everything,
right?
Yeah.
Oh you got problems in your life.
Could go to the gym.
Cool.
Go get a workout on to the next night.
Let's,
let's at least start there.
I think those are,
those are super powerful and to give some specific recommendations that if
you're not particularly prone to working out by yourself.
A couple of recommendations,
he's just going to sound funny,
but any kind of partner or group exercise and you can take your pick.
I think rock climbing is fantastic.
Any kind of belay system,
for instance?
No.
Any type of dance I have to recommend dance on the Jocko podcast.
Echo,
edit that out.
Acro Yoga even better.
I'm going to keep going here.
Okay.
We'll go to the black hole here
or it could be Thai boxing,
right?
Well somebody with pads interact with a fucking human being.
We like to say Jujitsu,
Jujitsu,
just you just involved with Jujitsu enough to get choked out on a regular basis.
No,
you actually,
you got a great list in here of a practical Gremlin.
Defense is what you call it.
You know,
you talk about,
and these are all all in the book that you put out all these little tricks.
They're not necessarily to combat depression.
There were just things for people to maybe do better in their lives.
Morning rituals.
You got productivity tricks,
you got people,
how do you face things that you're afraid of?
You've got the jar of awesome,
you got gymnastics,
you got acro Yoga,
but I'm not going to talk about that one.
But my point is you've got a bunch of these things written about in the book,
which I think is,
is very helpful to people.
Hey,
I got to put this out there too,
just because people are listening to this.
If you're in that zone,
one 800,
two seven,
three eight two five,
five suicide prevention line,
if you're there,
give it a call,
24 hours a day,
seven days a week.
Okay.
Get yourself help.
Get,
get through it brother.
And if you're prone to those
cycles,
also one of my very close friends,
uh,
who by the way,
extremely successful CEO,
so material professional success does not make you immune to this necessarily
and that should be reinforcing and reassuring for people.
Meaning to say the people you see on magazine covers,
they might very well be fighting the same battle that you are.
Something very,
very similar.
And,
uh,
what this friend of mine did,
extremely successful,
uh,
I mean top 1% by any measurement.
And uh,
he,
he got close to the edge number of times and he realized he didn't care about
himself,
but he cared about his promises that he made.
So he made a not an a non suicide pact with his brother because he knew that he
would never break his word to his brother even when he didn't care about himself
at all.
Which is another effective yeah
approach.
I believe that.
I know plenty of guys,
at least in my old job,
we definitely all cared more about our friends,
our brothers in the seal teams and we did about ourselves without question.
So that would be a,
uh,
a powerful thing there as well.
I'm going to,
I'm going to take it to you,
a little section here where you wrap this,
this section up with a book
back to the book.
My perfect storm was nothing permanent,
but of course it's far from the last storm.
All face there will be many more.
The key is building fires where you can warm yourself up as you wait for the
temp is to pass these fires.
The routines,
habits,
relationships,
and coping mechanisms you build,
help you to look at the rain and see fertilizer instead of a flood.
If you want the lushest green of life and you do
the grey part
is part of the natural cycle,
you are not flawed.
You human,
you have gifts to share with the world.
And when the darkness comes,
when you are fighting the demons,
just remember
I'm right there fighting with you.
You are not alone.
There was a large tribe around you and thousands of them are reading this book
right now.
The gyms I've found were forged in the struggle.
Never ever give up.
Much love to you and yours,
Tim.
Well,
it would appear that once again the,
the podcast went into the darkness a little bit
and
I think that's okay.
And again,
I think that having you on here,
Tim,
someone that certainly like you've just talked about comes across as outwardly
happy and successful and loving life and having you talk about these things and
having you put them in the book is is it real service to people I think is the
most important thing I've ever written.
Period,
hands down,
end of story.
And that's a bold statement.
That's a bold statement.
And I think the other thing is that people that aren't maybe necessarily in that
boat,
it's important that they learn to so that you can recognize,
look for signs,
understand some solutions that you can give to people
and also remember that the darkness that seems all consuming,
we've seen it time and time again.
We've seen it
and it's not,
it's not.
It is not stronger than the forces of good.
The darkness will subside and the light will win in the end.
So hold on,
fight on,
drive on
and look,
look into the distance out there.
Somewhere in all that darkness,
there is light,
there is hope,
and there is renewal and rebirth and there is joy.
And there is this thing,
this amazing thing,
this crazy thing,
this beautiful thing,
this horrifying thing,
this magnificent thing
that we call life.
And it isn't easy
and it wasn't meant to be easy,
but it is worth
every second
to live it.
And
with that,
I wanted to make sure that I pointed out that this book,
which is 700 and something pages long,
actually it's 600 and after cutting back five pages long,
20 pages,
this book is not in any way.
This book is not about a book about suicide.
This is a fraction.
Was it?
Five pages,
eight pages,
something like that.
I just wanted to make sure that
I covered the subject.
I don't think that most people are going to pick up the book and say,
Oh,
I've covered the suicide section.
No,
they leave that for me.
That's what that,
that's,
that's my job here.
Uh,
but the book,
it's what it really is,
is a compilation of all the lessons that you've learned,
talking to all the people that you've talked to on the podcast,
which is a wide range of different people.
And you taken that and distill that down.
For those of you people that go and listen to the Tim Ferriss podcast and you
go,
man,
what am I gonna I can't give this to,
I can do it with the two hours,
two and a half hours,
who has two and a half hours now you can get it done in 15 minutes.
You can get it the distilled version,
the,
the peak knowledge there and that,
that's what the book is.
All this information kind of distilled down into nice little digestible pieces,
like a reference book that you can look at,
which actually now we're going into questions zone.
By the way,
hot seat,
Tim Ferriss get some roles reversed.
Uh,
first question,
can I say something for her?
Yeah,
absolutely.
So I just wanted to also note for people who might be listening to this and
thinking to themselves,
well,
I'm not prone to depression and not prone to these dark periods.
The so called coping mechanisms that you would use to take yourself from bad to
so called normal.
They are also the same strategies you can use to go from normal to better or
from better too far better.
They're the same.
It's just,
it's just shifting into a higher gear.
That's a great point.
And I use a lot of those strategies.
Work out every day,
wake up early,
get after it.
Of course,
I read a lot.
Write a lot.
Okay.
And you know what?
I feel pretty damn good right now.
How's that?
How that maps
I feel better.
Yeah.
And to,
and to just put a button in.
And also I,
I have with using these different approaches for those people may be listening
to this and still feeling somewhat hopeless.
The dark periods have gotten shorter and then able to turn down the volume and
the joyful periods,
the zone,
like periods of productive periods have become a longer and brighter and you can
engineer that.
It just takes the right tool kit.
Love it.
Uh,
this is a good piece of the tool kit right here to speak in a toolkit.
Tools of titans,
um,
at speaking of the book,
this ties into it.
The book is filled with all kinds of good ideas and enticing options and they
all sound really good.
How do you take and pick the right path and not get distracted by all these
other shiny objects that are out there,
especially because the path is laid out and you think,
oh,
cool,
this,
oh,
this looks really good.
You know,
I'm going to do this.
Do what Tim Ferriss told me to do in this interview and I'm going to do that.
And then you get a week into it and you haven't,
you know,
you get,
it's hard.
You realize that it's hard.
You realize that you,
you don't like doing that thing and all of a sudden you go look for the next
solution and you end up jumping from solution to solution and you never get any
progress because you're too busy trying to chase this shiny object.
How do you resolve that?
Yeah.
Is it,
this is a common problem.
Uh,
you have for instance,
in the self help world,
you have seminar junkies.
I don't really do seminars,
but you have people who go to a different seminar every weekend.
They get all hopped up on enthusiasm,
take a lot of notes.
They do nothing from Monday to Friday and they hit another seminar.
It's like a junkie hit getting them getting a dope hit,
but they don't put in the work.
So the,
the way that you stack the deck
is by understanding behavioral modification in a,
in a few ways.
And you don't have to do a lot of reading about this,
but there are few unnecessary ingredients.
One is if you just look at the literature,
do less than you think you're capable of doing.
So what does that mean?
If you are a hundred pounds overweight and you are starting exercise after no
exercise for 20 years,
do not start off with five days a week.
Have an hour of running on a treadmill.
The pass fail threshold is too high.
So you said it first.
Let's get you to the gym.
That is priority number one.
So make it five minutes of walking on a treadmill two or three times a week.
Let's just say,
of course my preference would be weight training,
but makes an easy example.
Anything beyond that is bonus points.
When I write a book like this,
which is just a monster and like you said,
kind of a choose your own adventure book,
but two crappy pages a day.
Best writing advice I ever got.
Your threat,
your quota is two crappy pages a day.
You don't even have to use them.
But if you,
if you ha,
if you put up two crappy pages a day,
that is a successful day and it takes away the performance anxiety and the
procrastination.
If you've never flossed you want to floss front teeth,
that's it.
Get those,
get those pearly whites and the front done.
Actually I got an issue with that.
Okay.
If you break out the floss and you can't floss the rest of your teeth after you
could with your front one's got issues,
well get in the game and floss all your teeth people come on.
So I think,
I think we've got to get people there with the the gingerbread trail maybe
appropriate for the flossing conversation.
But so the point is though,
if you want to submit a behavior,
you have to break that behavior down into a few pieces.
One is just getting out the floss and starting.
Then the other is finishing the different components to it.
So if I can get someone to say five sessions as my general guideline,
make it as easy as possible so that you submit the first five sessions flossing
to the first front.
Do your front teeth.
Generally people are going to do more,
but you start there,
do it for five days,
don't do more.
Call me releasing Jocko.
We'll send a drone to your mum's floss
with shoe disease is boots.
Have Big Shoe licensed folks.
Don't let them do it.
So there's that.
The other piece that is very is incentives.
And what do mean by that is actually a guest on the podcast.
Derek Sivers,
who's an incredible entrepreneur and a sort of a philosopher programmer,
made millions of dollars,
donated it all to music education.
He's a real character.
But he said,
if information,
if more information were the answer,
we'd all be billionaires with six pack abs.
More version isn't,
it?
Is not the answer generally.
Uh,
of course there's good and bad information,
but I'll give you a great example and this is kind of a ridiculous one,
but it proves a point,
which is I have a friend named Agi Jacobs.
He's a writer and,
uh,
he wanted to get into better shape,
but he never been an athlete,
never really worked out.
It,
never watched his diet.
But there he is.
He's got one kid,
another one on the way,
and I'm skinny Jewish guy,
but he described his physique as a python that it's swallowed a goat physique.
So it wasn't morbidly obese,
but does not look enough.
Super Hot.
And,
uh,
he knew what to do.
He just wasn't doing it.
So he wrote a check to the American Nazi party for $1,000 and I believe it was
his best friend.
It's like merciless friend.
He gave this check too and he said,
if I don't lose 20 pounds by the end of next month,
something like that,
I want you to mail this check in.
Which would put his name Aja Jacobs,
known writer and Jew on the list of contributors for the American Nazi party.
He lost the 20 fucking pounds is the punchline and you can use sites like
coach.me or stick STC,
k k where you actually create an anti charity so that there's a nonprofit or
charity you'd rather nuke then give money to a,
you can actually put money into escrow and if you don't hit your goals and they
have referees and judges and so on,
that money goes to your anti charity and it sounds so ludicrous.
You could also do something simple like a betting pool.
I know people who've never lost weight and they,
let's say five coworkers each put in a hundred bucks and whoever changes their
body composition ideally rather than a scale,
right?
But using a,
uh,
a Dexa scan for instance,
gets the pot at the end and it is incredible how hard people will work to not
lose a and then B lose money.
I know two guys who worked at Google both fatties at the time and uh,
one of them is since lost more than,
I want to say 80 pounds and run a few marathons.
But it started with a commitment to go to the gym together.
And if anyone missed the session they had to pay the other person a dollar.
These are people who make a hundred thousand plus a year.
No problem.
And it worked is the is the funny part,
but incentives whenever you're like how can I change this behavior?
You need incentives.
So give your,
give your close friend who you know would love nothing more than,
than to see you humiliated pictures of you.
You're like fat ass bump just making this up.
But like whatever in like your tidy whities and if you don't lose x number of
pounds by y point in time,
those go on Instagram and a story like you will lose the weight I promised you.
But there need to be incentives.
Humans are incentive driven machines.
And so those [inaudible] now we're trying to narrow all this information.
Do you pick one?
Do you set a certain amount of time?
Like okay,
I'm going to stick with this program here.
Kettlebell swings at night,
right?
I'm gonna do 75 kettle bell swings at night.
Do you say I'm going to do this regardless of the outcome.
And I think you did this with podcasts too.
You said I'm going to do eight podcasts or six podcasts,
I'm going to record them regardless if I hate it,
it doesn't matter.
I'm committing to it.
So that's sort of a way to avoid distractions on other things as well.
Definitely.
So there,
there are two different aspects to that.
So the podcasting
was a goal,
but I always try to set goals where you can win even if you fail.
So these are goals that have side effects that carry over,
and Scott Adams,
creator of Dilbert talks about this and tools of titans actually he calls it
systems thinking,
and in the case of podcasting,
he did this with blogging.
I asked myself,
what can I take out of this in terms of skills and relationships?
Even if it bombs as podcast,
I can get better at asking questions,
which means getting better thinking I can start to minimize my verbal ticks,
both of which will help me to do research for books later and on down the list.
There were maybe 10 different things that I would benefit from even if the
podcast failed.
So six was this critical mass.
I tend to do things in terms of sessions five or six times.
It's usually my experimental minimum,
but for a period of time,
let's just say behavioral modification.
So kettlebell swings or fill in the blank,
some kind of dietary intervention.
I'm going to start with intermittent fasting.
Okay,
so I'm going to fast 16 to 18 hours a day.
I've done up to 10 days,
but let's just say I'm starting with 16 to 18 hours a day of fasting.
Then I will measure things.
It's a very,
I don't want to scare people off with scientific approach.
It's like you have to know what affects something is having.
So you can do that subjectively zero to 10 how do I feel?
Or you can look at things like number of reps weight's lifted.
I mean I'm up,
I have my mug of my mug of tea and my get after Ajiaco mug approved.
Thank God if I had an unapproved,
I look at all these knives on the table.
Uh,
but this is one of my training logs right here.
I ended,
I've had these training log since I was 16 so I like to treat most of my
behavioral experiments,
exercise experiments,
dietary experiments as a two week experiment.
And that's,
that's the minimal effective dose that I'll use in cases like that.
And I'll always do the fewest number of things possible.
So let's just say you,
have you read a book like this or any other,
I think I take the opposite approach.
Unfortunately.
Probably bad.
I'll just go as many as I can possibly get it.
Dot.
So,
so for those of you who don't know,
Jackie is a Cyborg,
he has a robot.
Uh,
but no,
I'm actually just an idiot.
Poorly programmed robot.
But the,
the,
the reason,
here's how I think about it.
When I'm looking at goals or I'm looking at behaviors,
I asked myself,
all right,
I'm really enthusiastic.
I have this list of 40 things that I might do.
Which of these,
if done well,
we'll make the others irrelevant or unnecessary.
I'm looking for a lead domino,
which of these will make all of the rest irrelevant?
Meaning I don't need to do them or easier.
And that is how I choose the behaviors or the goals to focus on.
And then once I have those,
just so I can control my variables to the extent possible.
So I'm changing my diet and six different exercise routines and my sleep all at
the same time.
I may not know which is contributing to higher reps in the Kettlebell swing,
right?
Maybe the Kettlebell swing is killing me,
but because I fixed my diet,
I'm actually recovering properly so you don't have to take it to that level.
Bj Fogg,
uh,
fog has done some very interesting work in this area.
Uh,
but I would say honestly you want to get good at training yourself and this is
going to sound ridiculous and it gives kind of ridiculous take a dog training
course or train a chicken chicken's or the most interesting because they don't
respond to negative reinforcement.
But maybe that's not jack goes away.
You need something you can like hit with a lash.
And Trina,
I don't know if that would be oh wolverines to do a so that if you train a
chicken,
clearly not,
I didn't even know that was actually a thing.
Well it is a,
it is a litmus test.
They're there,
there's a couple that I'm blanking on their name right now,
who trained more than 1500 species for espionage purposes at one point.
And they started as marine mammal trainers.
So they were training dolphins,
orchids,
etc. And you can't just roll up a newspaper and bad orca and hit it on the head
for a lot of reasons,
but it doesn't work.
So they have to use a positive reinforcement.
And the,
we,
the,
we really get into the weeds with this,
but they also use a reward marker or a witch or a bridge,
which is a clicker in this case or a whistle to indicate when the animal is
getting closer to the desired behaviors.
In the case of a chicken,
you could teach it to say turn counterclockwise or turn clockwise to take a
certain number of steps and then come back to you,
uh,
to receive feed.
You're only using feed.
Uh,
but you know,
the,
one of the quotes that I really liked from a trainer was you shouldn't be
allowed to have a child until you've been required to train a chicken.
Um,
and there's a lot of truth to that,
but it's just opera and classical conditioning.
But any,
anyway,
I could really go down the rabbit hole.
There's a great book called,
don't shoot the dog about this type of training.
Uh,
but I digress so that the point being understanding that we're all incentive
driven I think is is,
is very important.
And then trying to work on one or two things at a time because you're only doing
it for two weeks in,
in the way that I,
the mental model that I use.
And then you're assessing things and which by the way is why I generally
recommend if we're talking about diet,
so someone who needs to lose a hundred or 200 pounds and I've had the chance to
interact with a lot of these people and they've lost that weight.
Uh,
I will put them on a diet that has the,
there are three criteria that I use when I'm trying to say you design a diet for
an intervention for someone,
number one,
adherence.
So of a hundred people I told to do it,
well I have the highest percentage of compliance possible.
And you could tell people,
hey,
the best workout routine for losing weight is taping bowling balls to your hands
and doing wind sprints on but down a stadium stair,
well not too many of you are going to stick with that.
Uh,
so you look at the adherence,
then the effectiveness,
does it produce the desired result?
And then the efficiency of last in terms of is it uh,
is it time economical,
right?
Among other things.
But the point being a lot of folks give me shit on the Internet.
They're like,
what slow carb beans that'll make your intestines exploded.
I'm like,
Hey,
if your intestines explode,
like you're training yourself to be weak,
you need to fix your regimen.
But B,
uh,
you could throw a thousand people in a strict Paleo or strict veganism,
whatever your religion happens to be and a one out of a thousand are going to
make it.
Whereas if you use the gateway drug of say,
slow carb diet,
which is more convenient,
little easier at work with in two weeks,
let's say someone who weighs 300 pounds and has a hundred lose,
they'll probably lose between five and 10 pounds in the first 10 days.
So treating it as a two week experiment,
they now have the positive reinforcement and the results that will lead to a
credibility for me where I can drive them to do more ambitious things and step
by step that can then lead them to strict,
say Paleo or whatever.
But when you,
you have to start with the good program,
you practice is better than the perfect program.
You quit,
you see this an exercise all the time.
People come hot out of the gate and they quit four days later.
Really,
I don't know.
What you're talking about earlier is for for me is prioritize and execute.
We're to talk about in the book,
extreme ownership is,
you know,
what's the biggest impact are going to have,
make that thing,
take that thing to the top of list and start working on that one.
Yeah.
Done.
Yeah,
totally.
All right,
next question.
All right.
There was a friend of mine that was older than me and he was always looking for
the right girl and the right girl to settle down with and to marry and have kids
and all that stuff.
And it never seemed to happen.
And the reason it never seemed to happen is cause he was always looking for
perfection,
always looking for perfection.
And
I told him that,
you know,
profession doesn't exist.
And I also had another buddy of mine that was,
we were like surfing and he was always looking for like the next good time.
Always looking for,
he's looking for happiness.
Right.
And One time we're surfing and I go,
Bro,
you keep looking around for happiness.
This is it,
man.
We're surfing.
This is happiness right now.
Do you
ever feel like your search and too much and looking for something
it set of enjoying what you have?
10 years ago I would've said yes.
Right now I feel like I've found,
I found uh,
a few things,
meaning realizations and
I view my job as testing things on the fringe and reporting back.
Psych half like ethnobotanist might be eaten by cannibals plus a little bit of
athletic stupidity
and really trying to find the things that the extreme so I can inform the mean
and as an experimentalist or an experimenter,
I view that as my responsibility,
my job.
And I've,
I've also replaced a number of words in my life.
So we used happiness because it's just the easiest reference point for a lot of
folks.
Uh,
I think that the
better word is excitement.
So I chase what excites me.
Now that's a razor's edge you got to be careful with.
But when I say excite,
it means I wake up excited and I go to bed exhausted basically is what that
means.
And,
uh,
I've also realized that
there are things to optimize and their things to save her.
And I don't have a lot of trouble with that.
Most people would think that I'm just like speed reading poetry and watching
every movie on like 28 x forward with subtitles just to cram in as much Mr robot
as I can have,
whatever.
And No,
uh,
I,
I feel like I am increasingly better at the appreciation portion of the
equation.
The achievement I've always been,
I wouldn't say hardwired for,
but very well trained for.
I'm good at putting goals in the sites and achieving those goals.
But if you're constantly looking for the next thing,
whether it's the next goal or it's the next girl or it's the next high,
then you are never going to be operating in the present tense.
Was there something that you said 10 years ago?
If I would ask you this,
you would have probably been on your heels a little bit.
Is there something that happened when you said,
you know what,
what did I just,
you know,
did you get home from a trip one time and say,
what did I just do?
Or what was there a no,
I can tell you what I can tell you.
It was,
um,
so this,
this is related to something that,
uh,
you know,
Robert Rodriguez,
who's the director,
producer,
writer,
musician,
everything is fascinating guy.
Also huge.
I didn't realize how big it was.
So sin city go down the list,
right?
He's,
he has a,
a lot of hits.
And he said,
I always find it funny,
and I'm paraphrasing here,
but uh,
he's,
he's one of the longer chapters in the book.
He said,
I always find it funny when filmmakers come up to be brand new filmmakers and
they say nothing went the way it was supposed to go.
Like this happened and that happened and shit broke and then we missed this shot
and da Da da.
And he said,
they don't realize that that's their job,
that nothing is going to work.
Like if you're the director,
your job is nothing's going to work.
Uh,
so at one point I was feeling maybe existentially scattered.
I was like,
well,
I'm trying all these different things and doing all these different experiments
and what am I going to figure out my thing?
And then at some point someone just said,
no,
your thing is going Metta.
Like your thing is doing these types of experiments.
And what I realized is my,
my one thing is learning things quickly and whether that is cooking or
sniping,
I've taken some sniping courses.
That's a separate story.
A rally car racing,
whatever,
right?
Tango doesn't matter that the approach to deconstructing these things and learn
them quickly compounds.
So if I get better at one,
I get better the next,
it doesn't matter what the subject area is.
So that's my one thing.
Uh,
and it just gave me great peace of mind.
A,
you don't need one thing in a traditionally defined sense.
Maybe your thing is as I have found,
you know,
being a human Guinea pig and trying to train people to be better learners is my
one thing.
Uh,
and that,
that made me feel more confident,
uh,
in this sort of experimental approach.
I don't have 10 year plans and I used to,
that used to bother me a lot.
I am no longer remotely bothered by that because I have two week experiments and
have six month projects.
And if I do my,
we actually talked about this and you've written about it,
but rather than worrying about the next 17 promotions,
you just do what's in front of you.
In my case,
I'd say it's a book project.
If I do an exceptional job,
I knock it out of the park with this one thing.
Opportunities will present themselves that I couldn't have conceived of six
months ago.
And then it's just a matter of paddling for the wave.
But yeah,
but I'm a lot better at appreciation then I was along,
uh,
say 10 years ago,
because,
uh,
10 years ago it didn't matter how,
how will I did what I won,
what I accomplished.
I was always obsessing on the next thing.
You know,
I never took the time to actually enjoy it.
Good lesson.
All right.
And this is,
this is almost down the same line of thinking.
So we,
we,
I kind of see you as the king of outsourcing,
right?
Um,
but for me,
my whole life
I was doing a job that I absolutely loved,
a job that I wouldn't outsource to anybody ever.
And I feel like I was really lucky.
And even,
even right now I'm doing this podcast,
you know what I love doing this podcast and people have sent me,
hey,
we can help you,
you know,
set up for it and help you.
I would read books for you and give you notes.
I'm like,
no,
I don't want you to help me read books and give me knows I'm doing that.
That's what I'm doing.
So is there a job that would satisfy you that you said or what,
let me ask you this.
What jobs do you do that you took?
I own this thing and I'm not gonna let anybody else to do it.
The podcasts,
for instance,
my favorite part of book writing without the book writing,
it's fantastic.
And uh,
nobody's trying tried.
I don't have some like suit who's paid to manage the bottom line.
It would with no creative bone in his body trying to tell me how the podcast
should be run.
It's fantastic.
So I think that,
uh,
the podcast I could see doing indefinitely.
There are many things like that for me.
I mean,
I could see doing,
well,
I'll give an example just because I have to take the opportunity to talk about
tango on the Jocko podcast,
just to shave your nuts and we'll edit this out.
So the reason I stopped doing it,
I mean I got to got to the world championships.
Uh,
but the reason I stuck with I was a semifinalist,
so the world championships,
I didn't even know,
I can't even imagine what the world championships in tango is.
I don't think it was a dance work.
How do you attack the other people?
Like how do you get them out of the arena?
How do you throw them out on the right?
What happens?
It's a,
well,
it's a very delicate,
so there's points is their points or something.
They're judges and so on.
It's just like a,
like an odd diving competition,
zero to tender thing.
But the point being,
I stopped because I left in an environment in which it was highly competitive.
I went from Argentina where there are dozens,
hundreds of worldclass dancers to the u s where they're just,
uh,
are there's like seven,
a handful,
right?
Oh,
it's,
it's Bob again.
Okay,
great.
Uh,
so the,
the,
um,
the one thing honestly is teaching people to test assumptions and become better
learners.
That's it.
That's my thing.
So that's the one thing that's the constant through all the books through the
podcast.
Don't believe everything you think detached to use your word,
right.
Assess and test the assumptions and get better at getting better.
Ultimately,
that's it for me,
but I,
there are many things that I do now that I could see doing for a very,
very long decades,
for sure,
including the podcast.
Good.
The other podcasts,
we were talking about this earlier,
the great thing about the podcast is,
is that you can do whatever you want.
Oh yeah.
It can be three minutes long.
It can be three hours,
it could be 30 hours long.
You can talk about whatever you want.
No one's going to just do what you want.
And that's if you've written a book,
the amount of other people that start to weigh in on that thing,
it's,
it's can be a little bit that's not oppressive,
but it's just not as nice as,
hey,
I'm going to turn this on and do whatever I want.
Which is a good feeling.
All right.
And,
and speaking of doing whatever you want,
and I know that's kind of how you set your life up,
which is awesome,
but to take that,
that notion to the extreme,
if you got diagnosed with a horrible disease,
and I tried to think of a better way to ask you this question,
which isn't like majorly depressing cause this is,
but if you got diagnosed with the disease that was going to kill you in a year
or 18 months,
okay,
what
would you do with those months?
I,
so I role play this all the time.
Uh,
not,
not because I want to dwell in the darkness,
but this is part of the rehearsing the worst case scenario.
So not only do I rehearse this for myself,
but I try to spend time around people who are going to die.
And when I get back to the bay area,
I actually want to volunteer in a hospice center to contend with that.
Uh,
yeah,
there are a few things.
So I would,
I would get my affairs in order relatively quickly.
They're already largely in order so that my family would be taken care of.
And to be honest,
there aren't many points in my life where I could say this.
I would largely keep doing what I'm doing.
Honestly.
I think that,
okay,
I stopped,
for instance,
the tech investing about two years ago because I felt like I was replaceable.
I felt like if I in a sense didn't participate,
there were a hundred other people in line who are going to step up and write a
check.
And that wasn't a unique opportunity nor a unique skill that I held to
hopefully put into the world to benefit people in some way.
But,
uh,
the,
you know,
all the ludicrous experiments,
some more practical than others and the podcasting and so on.
I feel like I'm putting out the best work that I can and
I think I'd keep doing it.
And I'd certainly,
and,
and in the last few years I've,
uh,
after reading an essay,
I think it's called the tail end by Tim Urban on wait,
but why about how effectively by the time you're 18 and leave the house,
you've spent 80% of the total hours you were ever spend with your parents.
Uh,
I've reorganized my calendar and my year to spend a lot more time with my
family,
meaning my parents and my brother.
And
I think I'd keep doing what I'm doing honestly until,
uh,
until I slipped,
you know,
end up in a pile of dust,
which is where we're all ended up.
That's where we're ahead.
Sooner or later I was listening.
I keep wanting to do this.
I want to,
when I'm listening to certain podcasts,
sometimes I want to just live tweet.
Like when I'm having thoughts about them and I,
I do it with rogue and sometimes I go,
man,
I should just be live tweeting this.
Cause sometimes when he had,
who do you have on?
Oh,
when?
When he had Sam Harris on.
I was just,
there was so many things that they were saying that were just hilarious to me.
I don't want us to live tweet,
but when you had Shay,
Carl on the,
at one point,
I can't remember his quote,
there was this,
you got to this topic and you know you have what you would do.
And it wasn't the same question it was,
but it was somewhere in the same thing.
Maybe it was about money and he got enough money now or something along those
lines and kind of at the same time,
you know,
he says,
he says something like,
you know,
just imagine being able to spend all this time with your family.
And then you said at the same time,
cocaine in horse,
I wanted to live.
We've done.
That's cool.
Yeah.
Shay and I,
it's been a couple of days together
and which just for those people that have any context,
he's also raised Church of Latter Day saints,
Mormon,
Utah.
And uh,
so I was like cocaine and whores,
which is the nature of my podcast.
I left.
That was classic.
It's the little things.
It's a little bit,
that was another,
I want him to live through it cause he was saying to some really classic lines
in those as well.
All right.
Normal Day to day.
Okay.
No imminent death that I just placed with.
You're healed my son.
Thank you.
Demons,
no disease.
It seems like you've gone through your life going from all these different
hobbies.
You talked about tango,
you talk about Jiu Jitsu,
you wrestled,
you did judo when you were in Japan.
Now you're talking here,
we show up here.
You're talking about archery,
right?
You've got all these different things going on.
For me,
I've only had a couple things that have made me feel that way.
That thing,
right?
Number one is combat.
That's,
that's as good as it gets for me.
Jujitsu is the next thing down.
It's an empty brain and just awesome this and surfing is up there too.
Maybe jamming with my band,
getting it on in that way.
How come you're jumping around so much and is there anything that you always go
back to?
So I jumped around.
I had a,
I had a conversation about this with one of my very close friends,
Josh Waitzkin,
for those who don't know,
he's the inspiration for the book and the movie searching for Bobby Fischer.
He was a chess,
well considered a chess prodigy.
I take some issue with the name.
He doesn't like that label either.
Uh,
very good at learning just about anything.
He's also the first black belt under a,
a incredible Jujitsu athlete and teacher named Marcella Garcia legit who is at
deco finally jibes in.
Yeah,
I would echo and he just wants to point out that yes,
Marcello Garcia is low digit Marcello is one of the finest grapplers in the last
hundred years for sure.
And which,
which by the way makes him one of the best grapplers in the history of the world
and the universe.
Exactly.
Okay.
No,
this is completely true.
I mean,
I,
I've not to go down in the Marcello rabbit hole,
but uh,
yeah,
I had the opportunity to train with Marcello and it's just another planet.
It actually at Josh invited me when I,
when I get out to New York,
Josh said,
hey,
come on by the academy.
I'm like,
okay,
yeah,
no problem.
I'll be there.
So what am I going to get out there?
He's like,
oh,
we got ease.
And everybody's like,
you got everything.
Yeah,
this is like surface.
Oh,
it's,
it's a fantastic,
it's a fantastic school.
Cool.
And,
uh,
he's applied his learning approach to Jujitsu.
He's applied it to Tai Chi,
push hands.
He was a world champion and he's,
he's applied to a handful of things,
but not a lot.
He's not as,
as frenetic as I am,
but we've,
we've spent a lot of time together.
He's a very close friend and he said,
and this is his words,
not mine,
but he feels like I am one of the best people on the planet at getting people
from zero to 80% of a skill as quickly as possible.
And he's focused on the last 1% getting someone from 99 to 100.
So he works with some of the biggest names in the finance world.
Uh,
people who are very under the radar to get them from say beating 99.99% of the
competition,
2.999 and I think those are complimentary skill sets.
But for me,
the high that I get is different from the high Josh gets.
The high that I get is taking someone.
For instance,
I didn't learn this,
we talked about this.
I didn't learn to swim properly until I was in my thirties a for a host of
reasons I won't bore everybody with,
I did a Ted talk on why that is,
as absurd as it is,
but taking someone who hasn't,
hasn't been able to swim ever,
and getting them in two days to the point where they can swim,
say open water in the ocean for a half a mile,
which is completely feasible.
It's completely possible for someone who has some athletic background.
That's my high,
showing someone that the impossible or what they thought was impossible is not
only possible,
but in a timeframe that seems completely unrealistic.
That's my high.
So I think that's part of the reason I jump around is in part to learn,
but it's also being able to teach someone in a way that saves them hundreds of
hours and just to see their head go and you get that obviously,
then you get that satisfaction yourself when you try something for the first
time.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
There's,
there's nothing better for me.
I mean,
when I figure out,
for instance,
with with archery,
a blank bail practice and I'm like,
oh my God,
it's just like dry firing with a pistol.
Like to fix your like casting or healing.
It's like mine.
It's the same fucking thing.
Oh my God.
You know,
and then I get all excited because I'm piecing these things together or oh,
the way that you train someone,
figure out their eye dominance.
Like if you're constantly missing basketball shots by like an inch,
you probably haven't figured out your eye dominance.
It's like,
Oh,
then you shift your center line slightly.
So you're raising the ball in a different way.
Oh my God.
It applies in the same way to bowling,
even though no one even talked about bowling,
those types of things get me very excited.
I always thought I was going to be a teacher because I had these coaches and
teachers in ninth or 10th grade who steered me from this very bad path onto a
much better path.
I mean,
a lot of my friends growing up,
long island ended up overdosing,
dying.
My best friend growing up was one of them,
or drug addicts or alcoholics.
And I got steered in this other direction and that ninth,
10 grade window is what I always thought I would go back and teach.
So I love teaching,
so that's why I jump around.
But,
uh,
what,
what creates the zone for me is partially just that Aha moment is exciting for
me.
So I do spend a lot of my time looking for fertile ground.
So it's a new skillset,
but these skillsets compounds.
So the better you get at learning any skill,
the faster you'll learn subsequent skills.
Uh,
but if I had to default to a few activities,
I would say it's,
and I have to be trying to be smarter about this,
but it's a physical activity with a component of danger.
That's it.
It's a physical activity with a risk,
with real stakes of some type.
So that could be rally car racing,
just very physical.
It could be Jujitsu,
it could be a different martial arts,
a Thai kickboxing where I probably spent the most time outside of Jujitsu and
wrestling.
Uh,
those would be the activities that,
that put me in the zone by necessity because the penalties are so swift and so
immediate and so severe,
uh,
strongly incentivized to not think of the Alfre runs are going to hit when
someone's trying to kick you in the head.
Similar question.
Next one down the down the list here.
Now I was with a friend of mine the other day and we were doing some work on his
car,
just like bodywork,
right?
You're sanding and then you're polishing and then you're saying again,
you're polishing and you're paying priming all this stuff.
And there's a certain level of detachment and court sort of,
for lack of a better word,
like a zen mindset where you're doing this thing but you're not doing it right.
It's the same thing with cleaning guns.
You know,
you're cleaning guns,
you're just very,
it's just a very calming thing,
you know,
sometimes when I just need to relax,
I'll just clean my weapons.
I think everyone kind of does that.
But it do you do,
do you do that?
Is there anything that you do that you do that puts you in that state of mind of
that?
Just let's let you kind of relax?
Oh,
absolutely.
There are,
there are a number of them and I,
I view them as medicine.
I need consistent dosing of these things.
Uh,
the first few that come to mind,
uh,
swimming now that I do for fun,
which blows my mind to this day because I'm so terrified with it forever.
But swimming laps,
just a very repetitive left,
right,
left,
right?
That rhythm is hypnotic for me.
God,
somebody asked me the other day like,
Oh,
do you still swim?
I said,
no,
I surfed but I don't swim.
Like I swam enough my whole life swimming.
Swimming.
Yeah.
And I don't swim like I'm on purpose though.
So,
and the reason somebody said why I said boredom,
right?
Yeah.
Maybe I need to revisit that so that that boredom is,
is can be a positive thing.
It can be.
So I find this is Bonnie.
One of the reasons that I,
this is slightly,
this is different because you'd have to pay attention with this word,
but dog training.
Uh,
I wa I went really deep with dog training and for a lot of folks it's really
monotonous.
Shaping a behavior at a high level is extremely repetitive and I find it
therapeutic.
I love it.
Uh,
so swimming would be one.
And here's how I make swimming a little more interesting to me.
With swimming,
I focus on the efficiency of strokes per per line.
So you got little challenge.
I have a,
I have a game or I will look at instead of say,
right,
left,
breathe and then breathing to the alternate side.
So you're breathing every third stroke.
I'll try to do every fifth stroke and I have these metrics that I use to keep me
motivated.
That's the little Scooby snack.
And uh,
so cooking,
I find something I always hated until maybe three years ago,
no more,
five,
five years ago.
I find also very,
uh,
present state forcing.
It's a forcing function for me when you're trying to figure out five different
dishes going at the same time and timing everything.
You don't have any slack to think of other things.
And so I don't,
I very rarely cook for one person,
meaning myself,
but having groups over,
we had an entire pig for my birthday a few months ago and a spatchcocked for
those who don't know what that is,
is you basically splitting it down the middle and then spreading it out like a
pancake.
And uh,
we just created this raging inferno,
my back yard,
uh,
with a pig and fish and all this stuff and everybody was involved.
Probably 10 different people and I was not the,
uh,
the commander in chief for that one.
We,
that we have a friend who really knows what he's doing,
but just one of the most relaxing experiences that everybody had had.
Everyone came away from that after two days of being involved in it,
they said it felt like a six month vacation.
I think that this is a problem for me,
right?
In the military.
You starting really early in the military.
You eat for time,
you eat for,
to get food and fuel in your system.
And I'm really not a good relaxed.
Let's take some time,
prepare the meals,
sit around and eat it.
I'm shovel it in so we can go to more stuff as I don't enjoy that enough.
And I love eating.
I mean,
I love eating,
but I don't ever just sit and relax and eat.
I'm always in the game was like trying to get that food down so I can go and get
after it some more.
And any kind of detailed practice for me,
where I have immediate feedback,
uh,
is it can put me into that zone.
Uh,
shooting,
shooting steel,
I was just shooting steals.
Uh,
particularly if I'm doing any type of drilling at close distance with a handgun,
a,
although there are different types of feedback from me.
If I'm doing longer range marksmanship,
then I'm thinking more about a lot of my breathing and so on with the,
with pistols,
you know,
if I'm using a whatever glock 34 and then p 45,
whatever it might be,
uh,
the focusing on the subtleties of
predicting when you're going to pull the trigger,
the flinches and the sort of stutters and stammers that can affect the shot and
then making an adjustment and then taking the next 10 shots.
I just,
I find that endlessly interesting isn't the right word.
Endlessly focusing.
That's another thing that the military kind of screwed up for me because the
shooting in the military on the best ranges in the world with all unlimited
ammunition and all,
that's what your genes,
your job.
And so you get in this mode where you're just loving it and,
and then you get in the civilian world and you know,
you go to the range and the,
the ammunition costs money right here,
you're all angry about that.
And then they say,
oh,
you can't shoot steel in this range.
And what about moving targets?
What about,
you know,
I want things and you just get used to it.
So you get spoiled in the military a little bit.
And there's some great civilian ranges out there as well that offer the same
thing that I'm love to utilize.
It's awesome.
A good,
all right.
I like that there's some kind of a dichotomy between zen state and shooting,
but it's all in the Irish flute.
My preferred.
I'm kidding.
Okay,
cool.
All right,
now here's,
here's another one.
So when I retired from the navy and got out and started the consulting business
working in one of my risk averse friends that was staying in the military for,
it's
it's welfare program,
right?
It's a,
it's a paycheck.
Right?
And he,
the guy wasn't,
you know,
he wasn't all fired up anymore,
but he was in and so you had a mortgage to pay and kids to feed.
So he just staying in and he kind of looked at me when I was getting out and I
said,
yeah man,
I got bills to pay too,
but I'm gonna go and get after it somehow.
And he said,
what are you gonna do with it if it,
you know,
if the business doesn't work and you end up in a,
you know what,
you're going to come back in and about what,
what,
what are you going to do?
You won't be able to get back in,
blah,
blah blah.
And I said,
Bro,
worst case scenario,
everything goes to hell.
Guess what I'm going to be doing?
I have an Rv,
I will be in my RV with my family.
We'll be driving up and down the coast of California rating Jujitsu schools and
Training and I'll be surfing and it's all good and it won't cost me barely
anything to do that.
My retirement would cover,
would be good to go.
You got a backup plan like that?
Well,
let me,
let me rephrase that.
If you needed a backup plan like that,
what would it be?
This is,
this is one of my favorite topics.
Uh,
so I would say that I have an infinite number of backup plans and the way I
think about that is by doing what I call fierce setting.
So much like you just said,
looking at my goals,
the worst thing that could happen,
the weeds,
I could mitigate that and the way I could get back to where I am now if all hell
struck at once,
helps me to remove the fear of taking these,
these steps that paralyze me.
Otherwise.
The second part is by say,
practicing fasting,
practicing spending no money for certain periods of time.
I don't fear,
I would say the top handful of things that tend to stop people from taking what
they perceive as risks.
The other very important thing is that risk has a very specific meaning for me
and I realized early on that people talk about risk tolerance taking risks,
but if they don't define it clearly it can.
It can end up being paralyzing and how nebulous it is.
So for me,
risk is very simple.
It is the likelihood of an irreversible negative outcome.
That's it.
So most things I do,
even though people look at it,
they say,
oh my God,
this guy's in vec investing in speculative startups.
When it's just one guy in an idea,
man,
he's a risk taker.
I don't view myself that way.
All I view myself as if anything,
someone who's very has taken a lot of time to get good at mitigating risk.
I'm a risk mitigator.
Uh,
and in the case of say,
specular investing,
I am only using money that I can comfortably afford to lose.
And for me,
backup plan,
similar to yourself,
she and I throw my dog in an RV because it get them instant oatmeal sleeping
bag,
you know,
seventies right in my backyard.
I don't know how to go find some dirt bag climbers and hang out.
They're good to go.
Yeah,
go hang out with my parents,
get to see more of them.
Go for a run in the woods while I'm trying to figure out the next step.
[inaudible].
Then you had that attitude when you were taking more legitimate risks.
I mean,
right now,
obviously you're,
you're pretty good to go and,
but,
but in the beginning would you moved out to the west coast?
You have,
you had to have the similar attitude of,
because I know I did that,
that that attitude for me freed me like a worst case scenario.
I lose everything.
Cool.
I still have my RV.
It's paid for.
Yeah,
we're good.
totally.
I had that attitude,
surfboards and any other human should ever have and not knives and surfboards.
We roll deep.
I,
I think I had that realization early on and of course when I first graduated
from school,
went out to the west coast,
I did not have a lot of money.
I remember when I came out to California for the first time for a job interview,
I couldn't afford a hotel.
I stayed at the Fairtex kickboxing gym on the second floor,
sleeping on a bunk bed with a Thai instructor sleeping above me and washed my
clothes in the sink.
And I was happy.
I mean that I was fully content.
I didn't feel like I was missing anything.
And uh,
uh,
but let's not kid ourselves.
I mean,
when I first moved out,
it was 1999 this is at the peak of the bubble.
Rental prices are out of control and I was making 40 grand a year pretax and
it's um,
yeah.
And My,
my office,
my desk was in the fire
exit.
I mean they was completely illegal.
I was,
I had to,
I had a,
a pretty slick setup,
but it was very low budget and uh,
but really what I think freed me on some level is realizing in this,
hopefully this doesn't sound Turkish or arrogant or whatever,
but no matter what difficulties might be follow me,
whatever,
uh,
unemployment might come my way.
There are people with fewer resources,
with less education who have figured it out before and survived.
So if dozens or hundreds or thousands of millions of people have figured this
out,
I'm going to come out the other end and be fine.
And,
uh,
so that,
that was very reassuring to me that that is a good one.
Okay.
We'll move to the next question.
Any misconceptions about you that you want to clear up?
Well,
uh,
you,
you actually,
you actually confirmed a misconception for everybody tonight.
You said,
oh well,
you know,
Jack,
who's going to train somebody?
He's going to need to beat them.
And that's like,
people always think that and it's just so wrong,
so wrong,
so wrong.
I mean,
I,
I don't,
I'm not going to go into it now cause I talked about on the podcast all the time
that that stuff is ineffective and you,
you actually have to lead people and when you,
yeah,
so that was a good misconception.
You piled on.
I'll have Dalton,
I'll spend another five years trying to debunk that and prove to people that are
not a drill instructor with a lash.
But it's good.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
Which was,
was deliberate.
I'm just done
Jocko.
So effective at busting my balls on Twitter and then everyone takes it
literally.
I'm like,
okay,
well I have this opportunity.
But the,
so first misconception,
so the cocaine and Horace only twice a week folks,
it is not disabling.
Uh,
that's a joke.
Internet by the way.
So the,
I'd say the biggest misconception is,
uh,
and it's very understandable.
Look,
I mean,
my book titles,
I didn't expect the four hour thing to become a thing.
So the four hour workweek,
funny story behind that,
the,
the original idea for the title and I had dozens,
but the one that,
that I ended up testing first was the two hour work week,
which was about the amount of time I'm spending managing my company at the time.
And uh,
some people at the publisher like that's way too unrealistic to hours a week.
And I was like four.
And they're like,
that's so much better.
I was a good chin.
Perfect.
Nailed it.
And uh,
it sounds like a product you'd see after like the spray on hair and before the
rotisserie chicken at three in the morning.
And it sounds like a different person,
so I get it.
But the biggest misconception from people who have not read the book or books is
that I,
yeah.
Advocate idleness.
Oh,
okay.
And that's not the case.
I have no problem with hard work as long as it's focused on the right things.
So I think of maximizing per hour output.
That doesn't mean I advocate dropping a bunch of acid and like watching your cat
walk the House for 12 hours a day.
That doesn't do much good for anyone.
Uh,
so that,
that's the biggest misconception.
Yeah.
Uh,
I,
I have no problem with hard work.
I just am a whore doing something.
Well that shouldn't be done at all.
I think that's a waste of skill and a waste of energy,
uh,
that that's the biggest there.
There are plenty of other ones,
you know,
something to that you need to watch out for is just because you work hard
doesn't mean that you're doing good.
Right?
I mean,
there's,
there's a bunch of little sayings about that,
but just because you're working hard at getting up early and you think you're
getting after it,
you might be moving a lot,
but you're not making any progress.
And there's a big difference there.
And I think that's something that people need to work watch out for as well.
Right.
So the,
for instance,
I think the prioritize and execute
people need to stop.
I think that's such an important starting point.
Like what you do is infinitely more important than how you do something.
If you have a list of unimportant to do's and you're killing it with the
unimportant to do is that's,
that's still chalking up to a loss.
Yeah.
Uh,
and you're still losing my friend.
You're still losing at,
so for me it's,
I,
when people ask me about time management,
I'm like,
no,
no.
Like if you don't have time,
you don't have priorities.
So focus on the,
what should you be doing.
And for me,
you know,
if the effective executive by Peter Drucker is,
is the classic there.
Don't worry about your apps and your email management and so on.
Just read a book that's a few decades old that just talks about prioritizing.
Uh,
so the,
the biggest misconception.
Yeah,
just the whole four hour stick.
That is my blessing and my curse forever.
That part.
That's another reason why this is my first book with a four hour in the title.
Oh.
Hopefully it'll sell.
We'll see.
I also lost the Timothy and went to Tim just so I don't have to feel like I'm
going to chastise by my mom every time.
I'm like,
what made you interviewed Timothy on the first ones?
I don't know.
Sounded more official.
I have no idea.
I honestly have no idea.
Oh,
awesome.
All right.
Uh,
we're getting,
we've got one more question here.
Okay.
You as a leader,
right?
There's actually millions of people that follow you,
That listen to you,
that respect what you say.
Okay.
And they,
they truly follow your lead.
I mean,
clearly they follow your lead.
We saw this with,
uh,
with the,
the launch of where the release,
what's it called when a book comes out,
when my book comes out.
Yeah.
You'd kind of predicted everything that was going to happen to a tee of like
VIP.
When we talk about this book,
it's going to,
you know,
can people go and buy it?
That's good.
And so people clearly follow you and listen to what you say.
Okay.
As a leader,
and I don't know if you've for see yourself that way,
but you are a leader.
Okay.
Two questions.
One,
where do you think you fall short and too,
and more important?
Where are you trying to lead people?
Yeah,
these are good.
Uh,
so I haven't thought of myself as a leader,
but
I think that two terms sometimes get used interchangeably and I view them is
very different.
So as a leader,
if I'm looking through that lens at myself,
I think I'm very good at
affecting national conversations and steering the attention of groups to one
thing for sustained periods of time.
I think I'm very good at that and helping people to prioritize.
If I were to view myself as a manager,
I think I have many deficiencies.
Uh,
and one of them would be,
and this has been a help and a hindrance,
as many things are,
uh,
inpatients,
I have extremely high standards and hold myself too,
a ridiculous degree of expectation for perfection,
which of course it leads to a lot of the problems we've talked about earlier.
But on the flip side,
I get a lot done in part I think because that is a driver that can also damage
relationships very quickly and it can in a management environment,
uh,
cause hurt feelings and people to not put forth their best because they feel
like they're being criticized and not lauded for their successes.
And in part that is because as an athlete,
I really hope,
hopefully it doesn't sound weird.
I don't really care if it sounds weird actually in sports and in business,
my general feeling was,
and I remember a mentor early onset,
something like this to me,
he said,
don't tell me about the good stuff.
The good stuff takes care of itself.
Just tell me about the bad stuff.
And that's always been my personal policy for myself,
but that does not always translate well to team environments.
So that,
that I think is my,
my,
my homework that,
uh,
and,
and a deficit that I've been working hard to correct for the last few years is
getting better at managing people who do not necessarily conform to that mindset
at all times,
which I think can be,
uh,
a big problem when it's,
when it's out of control,
but that that would be the biggest deficit.
But if we're,
if we're defining leader as someone who can put forth a vision or an objective
or catalyze a movement and move attention and people in one direction,
I feel like I'm quite good at,
at,
at mitigating the risk of that.
Uh,
because for instance,
people think that the haters,
this is a very popular on the Internet and not all critics are haters of course,
important to be able to take criticism and feedback,
but many people who were thrust into a position where they have the opportunity
to lead people virtually on there,
on the Internet,
which is a huge responsibility.
And I take it extremely seriously,
worry about,
say their detractors causing problems.
It's not the detractors and my experience that can do the most damage.
It's the die hard fans who get the message role,
who get the directive and misinterpreted that that is where you have to do
damage control and to think ahead.
So I think,
I think I'm quite good at that as far as where I'm leading people,
if I'm leading them anywhere.
Uh,
I,
I've always,
I shouldn't say always,
but for the last at least five years thought of my goal as creating a benevolent
army of
super learners effectively who can teach intern 10 additional people each the
same skillset.
So to propagate a tool kit that enables people to be elite problem solvers
instead of accidental hap hazard problem creators is ha has been my goal for at
least the last five years.
Explicitly teaching people how to learn so they can teach people how to learn.
That's right.
And part of learning is problem solving.
So you were by by definition,
getting people who are good at dissecting problems,
testing assumptions.
That's where I'm leading people now.
That's,
that's solid.
I mean that's obviously a really positive thing.
I always talk about the fact that,
you know,
I want to help people learn how to learn.
I talk about that all the time and I've said that before on the podcast deal.
We will teach people how to,
not,
not what to think,
but how to think.
And obviously I'm not the same scale that you are in terms of volume of masses
of people,
but there's definitely some people out there that I think are following me in
some way.
And that might be a strong word,
but I always think of that.
What I'm trying to get people to do,
if you're following me,
I'm really trying to get you to follow yourself and lead yourself.
I don't,
you know,
lead yourself.
Okay,
you see it my path.
That's cool.
My Path was good.
I liked my path.
Now forger bath,
you know,
figure out where you want to go,
how you're going to get,
how you're going to get stronger,
how you're going to get faster,
how you're going to get smarter,
how you're going to get,
how you're going to get better.
And I always think that those answers work best when they don't come from
somebody else.
But when they come from yourself.
Absolutely.
And I think also the teaching people
how to learn,
uh,
enabling
my audience to learn how to learn.
And when I say that,
I mean 10 a hundred times faster than would be expected in a lot of domains.
That's only one leg of the stool.
So let's say they're three legs,
the other two would be teaching them to dissect and manage fear and then the
third leg would be teaching them to be emotionally aware and resilient in that I
think is covered largely by stoicism if you take it as a practice and not as
something to passively ingest.
Yep.
And I just talked about stoicism on my last podcast because somebody hit me up
on Twitter and says,
do you practice stoicism?
And I was like,
no,
I just said no because you have pretty terse on Twitter.
And,
and the guy kind of wrote back,
I don't want to say he was offended and I don't want to rehash the whole story
cause I just talked about in the last podcast,
but you know,
he said,
hey,
well,
you know what's wrong with stoicism?
And I wrote back,
I'm like,
man,
there's nothing wrong with stoicism.
I,
I get it.
But for me to say that I practice it or even that I learned it from studying the
agents is not true.
I didn't go to Princeton.
I,
you know,
I didn't study when I was in high school.
I wasn't an overachiever.
I was an underachiever.
I was,
uh,
I was up troublemaker.
So I didn't learn anything about stoicism until much later in my life.
My roots aren't,
my beliefs aren't founded on what I read.
They're founded on what I lived in.
It's just,
it,
does it make sense?
Yeah.
When I look at it now and people have always asked me,
are you gonna do moccasin rallies on the,
but I'm going to do Marcus Aurelius on the podcast.
And,
and really all I'd be saying does that look,
Marcus Aurelius said this thousands of years before I did awesome,
but I would love this,
be all educated,
but I wasn't.
I was just,
I went down the path that I went down and experience the things that I
experience in my life and I came to the same conclusions that
yeah,
these ancients came to.
So it's an interesting dynamic.
No,
it is.
And I think it's worth noting also that if you find anyone who is consistently
good at operating at a high level in stressful environments,
okay.
The tools are the same.
Exactly.
I mean,
if you read one of my favorite books,
Musashi historical fiction,
fantastic book,
it's all the same shit.
You read that Stoicism,
stoicism is,
Seneca was my real introduction,
but that didn't come into my life until 2004 so it was after graduation.
For those of you that want me to do Musashi on this podcast,
I'm not going to do it.
Not going to do Musashi,
not tell you why.
And if you've read it,
you know you can't,
you gotta go through Musashi to get to the end.
Yeah,
you got to go through the whole thing to get the edit.
It is one of the best rewards in all of literature to get to the end and the
end.
This is a,
what's a,
how many pages is Musashi's 900
massive book and it's,
and you have to read the whole thing and it's all good,
but it all comes in.
It's literally,
I think in my copy,
because I always laugh about this,
it is two or three pages from the end of the whole book is we're get to the end
of Musashi where you go,
damn,
that just happened.
Or the payoff,
the payoff is so good and the,
Oh and I'm not going to do it on here cause I obviously I'd have to give away
the payoff and so I'm not going to do that.
And you have to go and read Musashi.
It's,
it's awesome.
And the ending is just as good as it gets.
It's,
it's as good as it gets and it's historical fiction.
But that happened.
Oh,
that's documented.
Oh yeah.
And it doesn't get any better.
So read Musashi for yourself people.
Maybe I'll give a like a one year lead time and then I'll do it one year episode
100 maybe we'll do give people enough heads up.
Episode 100 we'll go back and do Musashi if I don't give a spoiler alert at the
beginning because when we saw she's good when you get to the end and go,
yeah,
that kind of like the Matrix.
What's that?
The move.
Is there like a spoiler at the end of the Matrix?
Oh,
does it end up?
I don't know man.
I got to watch more movies.
Echo Charles movies.
Highly recommended babe involves a pig.
I think you'd like a junk.
Then where did you go?
Did you watch that a bunch of times?
Then you've got some saved story,
right?
Yeah,
I do.
So I,
I tend to,
when I write books,
so then I don't feel isolated.
I will generally I write late at night.
That's what I do.
I sent this so I can do research and interviews and so on,
but I'll do my writing generally between 11:00 PM and 5:00 AM and so that I
don't feel like I'm sitting in a cave by myself.
I will generally listen to the same track or same album over and over again for
a given book.
That's how I focus.
And then I'll have a movie playing on mute in the background so that I feel like
there are other people in the room.
Now.
At one point I was like,
all right,
I've seen the Bourne identity 5,000 times.
I don't want to see it anymore.
I have seen,
because I was,
for the first book I've Seen Shaun of the dead,
which is a comedy 6,000 times.
I don't want to watch that anymore cause I'll just say,
I'll just watch it on repeat.
So I might watch a movie five times a night.
Okay,
let's go to Amazon prime.
And I pulled it up in the first movie that gets displayed as baby that a little
pig and farmer hogget and I put it on and I was like,
oh,
this is hilarious.
This is all right.
Well I'll pick a real movie after this.
And then I was like,
good God,
this is a fine film
and
no renegade duck anyway.
Uh,
so yeah.
Yeah.
Baby.
I don't think you'd actually like,
I think you'd be disgusted with my recommendation,
but I don't watch enough.
I don't watch a lot of movies.
Um,
I think you'd like Narcos,
which is a mini series.
I've heard of that.
That Pablo Escobar.
Right.
I think I've heard about that one then.
Then you're,
then you're jumping
into what,
like 30 hours of content that is own.
Yeah.
You're looking at about 20.
Then you're in the vortex.
You know what?
You don't want to watch that.
Like when I'm 78,
I'll watch narcos.
Put that on my list.
Did you have any questions?
Echo?
Yeah,
I have a question.
Sure.
Go Charles timing in for the second time.
Like I'm going to go to entrepreneurship.
Sure.
You know,
how it feels like anyway,
that it's kind of become like a trendy thing to be an entrepreneur.
Whereas a lot of times like you might even notice people,
they don't know what they want to do.
They didn't know what problem they want to solve or product they want to
develop.
They just want to be an entrepreneur because it,
it seems like it's like this cool,
the cool thing.
Now,
do you find that to be the case and if so,
is that a good thing?
Yes.
Entrepreneurship.
I think that it is highly romanticized and uh,
it's easy to believe all you gotta do is drop out of college.
And next thing you know,
you're a Zuckerberg and you have a company with billions of dollars.
But that's not how it works folks.
And uh,
so I,
I do think that entrepreneurship is a mindset.
You don't have to start a company to be an entrepreneur.
It's,
and if you were to look at the Spanish equivalent,
like empathy and dare to undertake it is someone who makes something happen and
you can innovate within a company that is not your own within an organization
that is not your own,
or you can create a company.
So someone who makes things happen at the end of the day.
So who is it?
Is it a,
are we in a boom cycle?
I think if we're looking at tech entrepreneurship,
absolutely.
Uh,
I think that there are certain experiences every human being should have,
even if they fail.
I do think that starting a business or enterprise,
even if it's a side Gig that they moonlight is worth the education.
Uh,
but there's a huge survivorship bias out there.
Meaning,
so you open a Barron's,
let's say,
and Lo and behold,
you see all these mutual funds advertising.
Oh my God,
they've had incredible returns for 10 years straight.
Well,
uh,
maybe they're just the mutual funds that happened to survive by luck for 10 or
20 years.
They haven't to place the right bets.
So of the 500,
well the other 490 or no longer advertising,
these are getting,
if you're getting a false sample size and you see that a lot with
entrepreneurship,
they don't talk enough about the failures.
They don't talk enough about the vast majority who will fill.
Is it good?
I think that it's good for certain groups.
It's certainly good for investors if they can play the game well because even if
there are thousand shitty ideas,
that might mean if more people,
a higher percentage of say high schoolers or college students or otherwise are
going into entrepreneurship,
that you get an extra five,
the change in the world at the end of the,
uh,
so I am,
I am a big fan of entrepreneurship even though much like anything else,
uh,
that is perceived as high risk and therefore treated sometimes it with reckless
abandon where people are throwing hail Mary's when they should be doing risk
management,
you're going to have a high fatality rate.
And uh,
I don't view that as a bad thing necessarily.
But I do think that,
and this is actually a question that Brian Johnson,
who was a friend of mine,
he started a company called brain tree.
It was sold for I think,
800 million cash to Ebay.
And,
uh,
he saddled,
Huh?
He said he,
uh,
so he,
he shows up in,
uh,
in tools of titans as well.
But the question that he has,
because he's constantly flooded with
various questions from entrepreneurs who want to make it hundred million
dollars,
say,
oh,
what should I do this?
Should I do that?
What about this idea?
What about that idea?
And he just asks them,
is it an itch or is it a burn?
And he's like,
if it's just a little itch,
don't do it.
You're going to fail.
Because for the other people out there where it's a burn,
they can't not do it.
They're gonna rip your face off.
And,
uh,
that I think is a very good question.
Uh,
and the,
you know,
the other one,
uh,
which I think originally came from,
we think about this now,
Vander holy fields.
First coach told them that he could be heavyweight or at the time they probably
cruiserweight champion of the world.
And he asked Amanda if you wanted to do it.
And uh,
he said he didn't know.
He had to ask his mom.
So he went back as his mom.
Yes,
I would like to do it.
And he said,
well,
is that,
is that a,
is that a dream or is that a goal?
Those are two very,
very different things.
So I think that,
uh,
if you feel like you can't not do it,
or on the flip side as I would probably approach it,
if you can look at it as a short term experiment where you're doing a phase one
to see if you can develop any traction and get 10 friends to buy whatever it
might be and you can cap the downside.
I always think about this first.
I don't think about the 800 million I might make.
How can I cap the downside?
Then by all means,
the you're,
you're taking in my opinion than measured intelligent approach.
Hey,
yeah.
Throw a bunch on the wall and see if anything sticks because that's not really
like the,
the trend,
the Fed,
you know,
that I mentioned,
that's not really what it says.
It's like saying,
I mean now we kind of have this emergence of like the grind work hard and that's
now that's kind of cool.
You know,
the,
the working 20 hours a week,
like that's kind of becoming like,
you know,
uh,
Gary v how,
you know,
grind and 20 hours a day.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's,
it's,
it can work.
I think that you just have to be careful.
What I would suggest everybody do,
and I'm not sure if it's still on Wikipedia,
I believe it is study cognitive biases.
Yeah.
Humans get themselves into a lot of trouble with cognitive biases,
whether it's sunk cost fallacy,
you've put x amount of money or time into something and therefore you continue
to put good money after bad because you feel like you have to make it back the
same way you lost it.
Or the the survivorship bias that I talked about,
you have,
there's a big difference between correlation and causation and things that
happened at the same time and things that,
for instance,
and things that cause something else to happen.
So you just have to ask like,
have a thousand people who do x,
how many are going to get the outcome that is being showcased?
And if the answer is,
I don't know,
then she'd be really careful about assuming that elites to be right.
Uh,
and for me it also comes back to the adherence.
So if I,
if I'm trying to coach a hundred entrepreneurs and if I'm talking to three
entrepreneurs,
it's very case by case.
But if I'm talking to a class,
which I did for a long time,
class of high tech entrepreneurs,
hundred students,
hypothetically,
I want the advice I give them to apply to the greatest percentage of people in
the class as possible or to be usable.
And if I say 20 hours a day,
there might be one or two mutans who can do that and sustain it.
The rest are going to flame out.
And for me in that environment,
it's about finding first the good program you can follow as opposed to the best
program that will knock out 99% but environment dependent.
Now,
if we're in buds,
okay,
that might be a different situation.
If you're training dogs for say,
military or police utilization,
probably a different story.
If you are looking for athletes for ultra endurance competition or 24 hour plus
competitions,
you are looking for mutants.
Make no mistake about it.
Uh,
but if I'm trying to encourage the greatest number of people to attempt
entrepreneurship and succeed,
then I'm going to adjust my advice accordingly.
Hey,
do you ever,
I get a lot of sleep.
For instance,
people are like,
oh my God,
that Ferris Guy,
he's a four hour,
you must get two hours of sleep at night.
I've done all sorts of weird stuff with sleep deprivation and I've done
polyphasic sleep where I've gotten whatever it is,
two to four hours a night for ages on end,
but my default is eight to nine hours a night.
I love sleep.
I'm sorry Jocko,
but I didn't love it.
Hey,
do you ever get like,
you know how like entrepreneurship as like this,
the trendy thing to do,
do you ever get annoyed when you see like Po Posers?
You know,
you know how they subscribe to all the things and then they always want to talk
about it and they use all the jargon?
You know,
I would say,
I'll tell you what annoys me more.
I don't mind people who are blissfully unaware and extremely enthusiastic
because quite frankly we,
well,
I shouldn't speak for everybody,
but I think everybody's been there.
Like,
I remember graduating in [inaudible] 99 all my God was I excited to get into
tech and entrepreneurship is,
I remember this back,
I,
I kind of knew a friend of a friend who sold a company for some ungodly sum of
money,
340 million.
I was like,
what?
That guy is smart,
but he's not that smart.
And it was a very exciting time.
And I don't think in that,
in that world that excitement can be undervalued really.
I think it's the fuel.
I think it's,
it's a big part of the fuel.
The people who bother me are the B players who think they're elan Musk or the,
or the once you're lucky,
couldn't pull it off twice.
He didn't attempt.
Like once you're lucky twice,
you're good.
The people who had good timing and now think they walk on water like the,
like the kind of,
they start like,
uh,
a course now.
Those kinds of guys.
Oh,
there a million different varieties.
And I mean,
I'd like,
I'd love to see them all around off a cliff,
like lemmings.
I mean they make me absolutely insane because the best of the best of the best
when you meet them,
they don't act like dicks.
Well,
I should take it back there.
Probably a few,
but in general,
they have nothing to prove.
They have nothing to prove.
Like Marcello Garcia.
He doesn't walk around with invisible lats syndrome like mean mugging people in
the street.
Are you kidding me?
He could.
He could destroy all.
He just doesn't,
he's so far above it.
He doesn't care and he's a nice guy to begin with.
But uh,
yeah,
the,
the folks who walk around with a lot of attitude and her acting,
here's the,
here's the description entitled people who feel like the world owes them
something.
Those people make me insane.
And there's a lot of,
in silicon valley,
as part of the reason I stopped all of my early stage tech investing two years
ago,
I was like,
I'm out.
This is no fun anymore for a lot of reasons.
But that was one of them.
I was like,
I'm sick of sitting down with people who have something sketched out on a piece
of paper and now they're asking for $20 million or $20 million valuation.
And I'm just like,
what have you done a good on Ya rate plan.
I know you want to change the world.
Like everybody I've talked to today with your photo sharing app.
Fantastic.
What have you built before?
Because you walked in here and like you're levitating cause you walk on water
and I appreciate the confidence slash arrogance,
but what have you actually built?
The entitlement is what I can't stand.
And uh,
one of my favorite answers,
I ask people a lot of the time.
If you could put anything on a billboard,
what would your answer be?
So there are a few favorites.
Discipline equals freedom.
That's one.
Another is no one owes you anything.
That's a good,
no one owes you anything.
It's from a multiple time world champion.
And,
uh,
yeah,
I think that,
uh,
by Hook or crook,
a lot of the entrepreneurs and otherwise who feel entitled will get served,
humbled by whether it's by competition or by the universe.
So I don't have to do it myself.
Yeah.
I was
going to say,
I don't think it even has anything to do with entrepreneurs.
You know,
you just get people that are accurate.
That's just the way it is.
Yeah.
It is interesting that he,
that guy.
Yeah.
My,
uh,
my brother,
he goes to San Francisco from time to time.
He has a tech company,
um,
and they,
uh,
he,
he said it's interesting that it's this fad now.
Like you have like groupies of tech entrepreneurship.
Like you have fanboys you have posers to be a business person.
You know,
it's not like,
you know,
like a rock star anymore.
It's like,
Ooh,
I'm a tech entrepreneur.
Oh yeah.
It's a weird environment.
But I'm very much of the opinion that as perverse as it might seem,
or as perverse as it is on many levels and weird and unsustainable,
there's good that will come from it.
The more entrance you have in the race.
It's just like the more freaks and mutans are going to find those people are
interesting.
So I'm cool with it.
I'm just going to wait until there's blood in the streets and the game's a
little easier for me.
All right,
Echo.
Yes.
Anyone wants to support this podcast?
How should they do it?
They do by the way,
if they hurt.
Yeah,
on Twitter and whatnot,
they do.
And here's the way.
First off,
support yourself as I always say,
if you didn't know Tim Ferriss,
I know you know about this stuff.
What I'm gonna say it anyway.
Supplementation,
talk about efficiency from time to time.
I know
shroom tech utilizes oxygen of more efficiently in your body.
That's what shroom tech sport is for.
Did I already say that before you said it before anyway,
it has a bunch of stuff that's on it.
That's the supplementation that you want to engage in because you don't want
junk supplements.
So they'll go on at dotcom slash Jocko,
get 10 10% off and supplement your wallet as well.
And then of course the Amazon Click through Christmas is coming up.
Christmas has going
various birthdays.
I'm not going to say when mine is,
but it's soon.
If you shop on Amazon,
click through our website,
you can support this podcast in that,
uh,
in that way you,
you're in the mood to,
um,
so yeah,
you go to the website Jocko,
podcast.com and click through and then do your shopping regardless of what
you're buying,
whether or not you're buying Tim's book tools for titans or uh,
or duct tape,
right?
You could buy some duct tape on there.
You can buy tools of titans.
You could actually use duct tape to make a handle and turn it into a kettle
book.
As you know,
it's a big book.
You can get Jocko white tea,
which is because it's back,
it's back.
We're there by the time this podcast readings,
I think we'll be there.
We ordered a ton this time so you can get it,
you can buy the book extreme ownership.
And if you don't have enough Jocko,
Jocko does make a number of cameo appearances in tools of titans.
That is right.
That is a,
I am in tools of titans,
which is awesome and I appreciate you,
uh,
you throw in in there gores and um,
and just a ton of ton of other great information.
Um,
also got some mugs coming.
You can buy mugs.
It was a good month.
They say they,
I tried to keep it simple.
You don't,
if they say on it,
they say get after it because that's pretty much their answer to everything,
right?
Yeah.
And you can kinda tell like,
cause it's going to be knock offs potentially.
There's like a,
an official,
it's been approved Jocko,
Jocko proof.
Some people if they get bumper stickers,
which I might mention in a bit,
but the envelope that comes,
some of them are Jocko approved.
That's all I'm gonna say.
Yeah.
These mugs,
these are manly mugs.
I could fit probably,
yeah.
My entire fist into this mug.
If you get chased by a Cassowary,
you could probably crack at skull with this.
It's a,
it's very functional piece of porcelain were or whatever.
It may matter.
You do carbon fiber.
Maybe that's what we'd want to purpose.
What else?
Well,
of course we have the store Jocko store.
If you like shirts,
if you wear tee shirts from time to time,
hoodies,
winter coming up went to the United States.
Australia,
it might be different,
but um,
you know,
the,
the heavier hoodies,
but yeah,
sure.
It's if you like,
um,
shirts and whatnot,
check them out,
see which one you like.
And then if you buy one of those,
that's a good way to support the podcast if you're in the mood to do so.
And as Jocko said,
the trail,
the mugs and I'm gonna change the,
the,
the travel mugs.
Okay.
We're going to improve them.
We're,
we're,
we,
we approved that.
There you go.
I like it.
Boom.
Yeah.
But yeah,
go on there.
See what up.
Subscribe your podcast.
Yeah.
You described the Tim Ferriss podcast if you don't already.
Probably do.
Most people do.
Yeah.
Check it out.
Just past was just going to say,
just passed 100 million downloads the first business interview podcast to do.
So.
When are you going to start stepping up your game though?
I know every day I'm trying to step up my game and the youtube channel,
which echo has now begun to engage in,
which is appreciated by all of us.
Me Over here.
I'm appreciating it.
Yeah.
So thank you for doing that.
There's more videos coming out.
Excerpts.
Yeah.
So I,
I do have to kind of disclose disclaim,
whichever.
Oh,
so I was going into,
uh,
through a camera transition phase.
So the excerpts,
there was a small delay on that,
but the,
the,
the transition phase is over and we're good to go.
So we'll do more,
um,
excerpt stuff.
I want to make another disclaimer and disclosure,
which is a,
for those of you see this on video,
I apologize for shopping at gap kids for my shirt.
These guys are fucking huge animals and I wanted to feel more competent
gap kids.
I like it.
Anything else?
Oh,
you know,
that's it.
Eight also,
we did it the extreme ownership muster in San Diego,
California.
It was awesome.
If you want to come
and you're on the east coast,
do you want to come?
May 4th and fifth,
2017 extreme ownership muster number two in New York City Marriott,
Grand Marquis.
It's going to be awesome.
And I'm going to tell you,
I've,
I haven't said it yet on the podcast because I wanted to give people the
opportunity that are already in the game and are tracking to get there,
but it's gonna sell out.
It's selling really quickly.
So if you want to come by now,
extreme ownership muster,
you'll probably come to this one.
Yeah,
it's in my back yard.
Well,
if I'm on the,
on the east coast especially,
you missed the first one,
but it's all good.
Hold it against you.
I won't even get into the apology and the explanation.
I'm looking forward to number two.
Awesome.
Uh,
Tim,
you got any closing comments?
Closing comment,
just to bring it back to the very beginning.
Uh,
if you're feeling alone with whatever doubts,
challenges you might have,
you're not alone.
You're far from it.
And honestly at this point that if I've learned anything from interacting with
hundreds of thousands and millions of people on the blog to the podcast,
okay,
all humans have the same problems and at the very least you have a large
brotherhood and sisterhood.
Thousands of people at a minimum who are feeling going through the exact same
thing that you are.
So do not feel alone.
And uh,
that's,
that's pretty much it.
I would say a,
there's some samples up.
People want check it out from tools of titans.
Uh,
I was,
it's,
it's surreal for me,
but Arnold Schwarzenegger wrote the forward,
which is incredible.
He's in the book and that's up.
The introduction is up.
How do use this books,
if you wanna check that out,
you just go to tools of titans.com
and if you want to continue this conversation,
by the way,
you can find all three of us out there on the interwebs.
You can find us on Twitter,
on Instagram and get no,
you can even find us.
Oh,
that face he Baja Echo.
Is that Echo Charles?
I am at jockowillink and of course Tim Ferriss is t Ferris.
Yeah,
two r's and two s's on Twitter.
Tim Ferriss on Instagram and of course he's also on that Facebook.
He's not hard to find and to everybody
that's listening,
I want to say thanks to Tim.
Thanks Tim for coming on.
Thanks to Tim for actually getting me to do a podcast.
It was you and Joe Rogan.
You.
As soon as you press record on our first one,
you press it.
You press stop.
You looked at me and said,
you need to do your own podcast.
And I was pretty packed for time right then because the book was coming out,
but as soon as Joe Rogan said it did have you to tell me that I was in.
So thank you for making me do this podcast.
Thanks for coming on.
Appreciate all the support that you've been given me and an echo and the podcast
and the book and everything else.
Thank you.
It's
much appreciated to everybody else that's listening.
Thanks to you for listening.
First and foremost to the people out there in uniform,
military,
police,
firefighters,
paramedics.
By the nature of your very job,
you are serving all of us.
So thank you for that service and thank you for the freedom and security that
you provide us
and rest of the people out there,
the troopers out there that have your own battles around the world,
fighting against apathy,
fighting against mediocrity and fighting like we all do.
Sometimes fighting against the darkness
to you all remember,
remember that this isn't easy for anyone
remembered that anything worth anything is worth fighting for.
Remember that the battle doesn't fight itself.
You are the one that has to fight it.
Remember that there's a price for victory
and that price is hard work and early mornings and late nights.
And that price is unmitigated daily discipline in all things.
In those times when you can't remember everything I just said,
just remember this one thing,
to get out there
and get after it.
So until next time,
this is Tim,
an echo and Jocko
out.